Welcome, everyone, to another episode. Excited to have a guest here today who is going to help us to revisit Python. I think Jason was saying it's been about a decade since the last time we had Python as the topic of an episode. I don't even remember what we were doing back then. It feels like a long time ago. But excited to have it. I have a love-hate relationship with python so i hear that there's going to be some work to sort of convince me to drop the hate part and just embrace the love part uh but maybe some of that comes from from years ago but i do respect that you know python has uh in some ways stood the test of time it's really there it's uh pervasive and it's helped so
Welcome, everyone, to another episode. Excited to have a guest here today who is going to help us to revisit Python. I think Jason was saying it's been about a decade since the last time we had Python as the topic of an episode. I don't even remember what we were doing back then. It feels like a long time ago. But excited to have it. I have a love-hate relationship with python so i hear that there's going to be some work to sort of convince me to drop the hate part and just embrace the love part uh but maybe some of that comes from from years ago but i do respect that you know python has uh in some ways stood the test of time it's really there it's uh pervasive and it's helped so|||欢迎大家收听新的一期节目。今天很高兴请到了一位嘉宾，他将带我们重新审视 Python。我想 Jason 刚才说过，上一次我们以 Python 为节目主题大概已经是十年前的事了。我都记不清那时候我们在干什么了。感觉是很久以前的事了。但很高兴能聊这个话题。我对 Python 怀有一种爱恨交织的感情，所以我听说今天会有一些内容来试着说服我抛弃恨的那部分，去拥抱爱的部分。呃，也许这种情绪有一部分来自于多年前，但我确实很尊重 Python 呢，它在某些方面经受住了时间的考验，它确实存在，它无处不在，而且它帮助了如此|||many people get into programming it's made so advances, so I'm excited to talk about it. So as I mentioned, we have here today Jason C. McDonald. He is the principal Python engineering consultant at Rule Sourcing and author of the book Dead Simple Python from No Starch Press. Welcome to the show, Jason. Hey, thank you. Thank you for having me. Well, we typically start off all these interviews. I know, like, want to dig into Python. I'm already ramped up. I'm excited. Even though it's a little early in the morning when we're recording this, but I'm ready to go. Let's talk a little bit about how you got into tech or programming.|||多的人进入了编程领域，它取得了如此巨大的进步，所以我很高兴能谈论它。正如我所提到的，我们今天请到了 Jason C. McDonald。他是 Rule Sourcing 的首席 Python 工程顾问，也是 No Starch Press 出版社出版的《Dead Simple Python》一书的作者。欢迎来到节目，Jason。嘿，谢谢。谢谢邀请我。嗯，我们通常都会以这样的方式开始这些采访。我知道，比如，很想深入探讨 Python。我已经进入状态了。我很兴奋。尽管我们录音的时候还是清晨，但我已经准备好了。我们来聊聊你是怎么进入科技或编程领域的吧。
many people get into programming it's made so advances, so I'm excited to talk about it. So as I mentioned, we have here today Jason C. McDonald. He is the principal Python engineering consultant at Rule Sourcing and author of the book Dead Simple Python from No Starch Press. Welcome to the show, Jason. Hey, thank you. Thank you for having me. Well, we typically start off all these interviews. I know, like, want to dig into Python. I'm already ramped up. I'm excited. Even though it's a little early in the morning when we're recording this, but I'm ready to go. Let's talk a little bit about how you got into tech or programming.
很多人进入编程领域，是因为它的发展太快了，所以我很高兴能聊聊这个话题。正如我刚才提到的，我们今天请到了杰森·C·麦克唐纳。他是规则采购公司的首席Python工程顾问，也是无淀粉出版社出版的《绝对简单的Python》一书的作者。欢迎来到节目，杰森。嘿，谢谢你。谢谢你邀请我。嗯，我们通常都会以这样的方式开始这些采访。我知道，比如，很想深入了解Python。我已经进入状态了，我很兴奋。尽管我们录音的时候还是大清早，但我已经准备好了。我们来聊聊你是如何进入科技或编程领域的吧。
Do you remember, like, your first computer or your first programming experience? Like, what was it that kind of, like, made it real for you? Oh, yes. Okay. Well, I have two first experiences i would say my first first experience was when i was 14 and i wanted to um do some coding to be able to build a game i was wanting to make and so i fired up python tried learning it hated it not just not just python programming as a whole hated it despised the whole activity.
Do you remember, like, your first computer or your first programming experience? Like, what was it that kind of, like, made it real for you? Oh, yes. Okay. Well, I have two first experiences i would say my first first experience was when i was 14 and i wanted to um do some coding to be able to build a game i was wanting to make and so i fired up python tried learning it hated it not just not just python programming as a whole hated it despised the whole activity.|||你还记得你的第一台电脑或第一次编程经历吗？比如说，是什么让你对编程有了真实的实感？哦，是的。好的。嗯，我有两次“第一次”经历，可以说我的第一次经历是在我 14 岁的时候，当时我想……做一些编程，以便能够构建一个我想制作的游戏，所以我启动了 Python，尝试学习它，结果讨厌它——不仅是……不只是 Python，对整个编程都感到讨厌，鄙视整个活动。
Was miserable with it. Gave up after two days and vowed to never touch it again. Fast forward several years. By this point, I am on the other side of a traumatic brain injury. Fell down a staircase my sophomore year in high school. Hit my head on the banister and went from a 4.0 sophomore collegelevel reading to failing pre-K material. Had to work my way back up. The way I explain my head injury is, if you're familiar with the BBC sci-fi Doctor Who, I basically am the doctor in that it's still fundamentally me under here, but I have actually had three head injuries in my life, and each time it has fundamentally rewritten my personality, my skill set, my cognitive ability.
Was miserable with it. Gave up after two days and vowed to never touch it again. Fast forward several years. By this point, I am on the other side of a traumatic brain injury. Fell down a staircase my sophomore year in high school. Hit my head on the banister and went from a 4.0 sophomore collegelevel reading to failing pre-K material. Had to work my way back up. The way I explain my head injury is, if you're familiar with the BBC sci-fi Doctor Who, I basically am the doctor in that it's still fundamentally me under here, but I have actually had three head injuries in my life, and each time it has fundamentally rewritten my personality, my skill set, my cognitive ability.|||那时候简直痛苦不堪。坚持了两天就放弃了，并发誓再也不碰它了。时间快进几年。此时，我正经历着创伤性脑损伤的恢复期。我在高二时从楼梯上摔了下来。头撞在扶手上，阅读水平从高二的 4.0 绩优生直接跌到了连幼儿园学前班水平都不及格。我不得不一点点重新爬上来。我解释我头部受伤的方式是，如果你熟悉 BBC 的科幻剧《神秘博士》，我基本上就是那个博士——底色依然是原本的我，但我一生中实际上经历过三次头部受伤，每一次都从根本上重写了我的性格、我的技能组合、我的认知能力。
It's still me. The core of who I am does not change, but it expresses itself very differently. And so I'm on my fourth. Basically, I'm in my fourth form. But after that 2008 head injury, discovered oh i like coding it made sense it clicked for me and started out with well at first i thought you had to have a degree to do it so i kind of came in by the back door by a vb script and then uh from there picked up visual basic.net and then from there discovered that that that uh ecosystem was too constraining for what i
It's still me. The core of who I am does not change, but it expresses itself very differently. And so I'm on my fourth. Basically, I'm in my fourth form. But after that 2008 head injury, discovered oh i like coding it made sense it clicked for me and started out with well at first i thought you had to have a degree to do it so i kind of came in by the back door by a vb script and then uh from there picked up visual basic.net and then from there discovered that that that uh ecosystem was too constraining for what i|||依然是我。我内心的核心没有改变，但它的表达方式非常不同。所以现在我迎来了第四个形态。基本上，我处于我的第四种形态。但在 2008 年的那次头部受伤之后，我发现，哦，我喜欢编程，这说得通，它对我有开窍的感觉，然后最开始——起初我以为你必须得有学位才能做这个，所以我有点像走后门，通过 VBScript 进入，然后……从那里开始接触了 Visual Basic.Net，接着发现那个生态系统对我想做的事情来说太受限制了，|||
wanted to do and so i thought huh i remember this python thing back from when i was 14 and i hated it then but you know i like coding now so let's try it again so was vb script your second head injury no no the second head injury was the was that staircase when i was 16 but uh no vb script it wasn't it was an interesting language it was a good introduction to it but i still to this day have no idea why you instantiate anything with dim i understand what it means i understand the history it still makes zero sense yeah for people can you uh it may be dating or something, but what is VBScript? What was it used for? So VBScript, Visual Basic Script, this was used in applications, still is actually, in applications like Microsoft Word, Microsoft Excel.
wanted to do and so i thought huh i remember this python thing back from when i was 14 and i hated it then but you know i like coding now so let's try it again so was vb script your second head injury no no the second head injury was the was that staircase when i was 16 but uh no vb script it wasn't it was an interesting language it was a good introduction to it but i still to this day have no idea why you instantiate anything with dim i understand what it means i understand the history it still makes zero sense yeah for people can you uh it may be dating or something, but what is VBScript? What was it used for? So VBScript, Visual Basic Script, this was used in applications, still is actually, in applications like Microsoft Word, Microsoft Excel.|||所以我心想，嗯，我记得 14 岁时接触过这个叫 Python 的东西，当时我很讨厌它，但你知道的，我现在喜欢编程了，所以让我们再试一次。那么 VBScript 是你的第二次脑损伤吗？不，不，第二次脑损伤是……我 16 岁时从楼梯上摔下来的那次，但是……不，VBScript 可不是，它是一门有趣的语言，是一个很好的入门语言，但我直到今天还是不知道为什么你要用 `dim` 来实例化任何东西。我明白它的含义，我也理解这段历史，但它依然毫无逻辑可言。是的，对大家来说，你能……这可能会暴露年龄或者别的什么，但什么是 VBScript？它是用来做什么的？所以 VBScript，Visual Basic Script，它被用在应用程序中，实际上现在还在用，比如微软的 Word、微软的 Excel 等应用程序中。
You can write macros, which are basically just actions that you can perform on top of Office. The context I was using it in was this was this um game software that because of the scammy nature of the business behind it i'm not going to name but um it was this game building software and they use vb script as a scripting language and that was where i got my my first taste of programming so i learned vb script fell in love with the fact that i could call up a dialogue box that says hello world on the screen i'm like this is awesome and yeah it's so true from there yeah that's a big part of it is having that kind of ripple where like you do something and you see so you see an action right off the bat right and
You can write macros, which are basically just actions that you can perform on top of Office. The context I was using it in was this was this um game software that because of the scammy nature of the business behind it i'm not going to name but um it was this game building software and they use vb script as a scripting language and that was where i got my my first taste of programming so i learned vb script fell in love with the fact that i could call up a dialogue box that says hello world on the screen i'm like this is awesome and yeah it's so true from there yeah that's a big part of it is having that kind of ripple where like you do something and you see so you see an action right off the bat right and|||你可以编写宏，这基本上就是你在 Office 之上可以执行的操作。我当时使用它的背景是，这是一款游戏构建软件，由于其背后的商业性质有些骗局性质，我就不点名了，嗯……这是一款游戏制作软件，他们使用 VBScript 作为脚本语言，这就是我第一次尝到编程滋味的地方。所以我学习了 VBScript，爱上了这样一件事：我可以在屏幕上呼出一个写着“Hello World”的对话框，当时我想，这太酷了！是的，确实如此，从那以后……是的，这其中很大一部分原因在于那种连锁反应，你做了一件事，然后立刻就能看到结果，你马上就能看到一个动作，对吧，而且|||
not even just an action but like a full-blown dialogue box of a yes and a no button and you click it it does something different I'm like like, oh my gosh, this is amazing. I feel so powerful. I became deeply, I became addicted to dialogue boxes for about two years after that point. I loved them. So. Oh, wow. All right. So I think we foreshadowed it by the fact that you may or may not have eventually written a book, but you returned to Python and after that, and how did that second experience go? The second experience was definitely a lot smoother. So as I mentioned, I felt very constrained by the.NET ecosystem for what I wanted to do. So I picked up Python and immediately hit a wall.
not even just an action but like a full-blown dialogue box of a yes and a no button and you click it it does something different I'm like like, oh my gosh, this is amazing. I feel so powerful. I became deeply, I became addicted to dialogue boxes for about two years after that point. I loved them. So. Oh, wow. All right. So I think we foreshadowed it by the fact that you may or may not have eventually written a book, but you returned to Python and after that, and how did that second experience go? The second experience was definitely a lot smoother. So as I mentioned, I felt very constrained by the.NET ecosystem for what I wanted to do. So I picked up Python and immediately hit a wall.|||不仅仅是一个动作，而是一个功能完备的对话框，上面有“是”和“否”按钮，你点击它，它就会执行不同的操作，我当时就想，哦天哪，这太神奇了。我感觉自己太强大了。在那之后的两年里，我深深地、甚至可以说是沉迷于对话框。我太喜欢它们了。所以……哦，哇。好吧。我想我们之前已经暗示过了，你最终可能写了一本书，也可能没有，但你后来重回 Python 的怀抱，那第二次经历进展得怎么样？第二次经历明显顺畅多了。正如我所提到的，对于我想做的事情，我感到 .NET 生态系统限制重重。所以我拿起了 Python，然后立刻撞墙了。
And I was going, how do you declare a data type in Python? This is weird. I'm used to declaring the type of my variable. So I log into the Python channel on the IRC network. That channel is still there. Just jump networks is now on the Libera chat IRC network, if anyone's curious. And I'm still in there.
And I was going, how do you declare a data type in Python? This is weird. I'm used to declaring the type of my variable. So I log into the Python channel on the IRC network. That channel is still there. Just jump networks is now on the Libera chat IRC network, if anyone's curious. And I'm still in there.|||我当时就在想，在 Python 里怎么声明数据类型？这太奇怪了。我习惯了声明变量的类型。所以我登录了 IRC 网络上的 Python 频道。那个频道现在还在。如果有人好奇的话，切换网络后，它现在在 Libera chat IRC 网络上。我至今还在那个频道里。
And anyway, my first question ever in that room was, how do you declare a data type? And one of the moderators slash room regulars responded with, you're a data type. And then proceeded to explain dynamic typing and for reasons i don't fully understand at that exact moment it became my favorite language because the just the part of it was the fact that it could figure out what it was doing and part of it was just the kind of the snarky somewhat irreverent Monty Python-esque attitude that it
And anyway, my first question ever in that room was, how do you declare a data type? And one of the moderators slash room regulars responded with, you're a data type. And then proceeded to explain dynamic typing and for reasons i don't fully understand at that exact moment it became my favorite language because the just the part of it was the fact that it could figure out what it was doing and part of it was just the kind of the snarky somewhat irreverent Monty Python-esque attitude that it|||总之，我在那个房间里的第一个问题就是：怎么声明数据类型？其中一个版主兼房间常客回答说：“你就是个数据类型。”然后接着解释了动态类型。由于某些我当时并非完全理解的原因，它成了我最喜欢的语言。一部分原因在于它能自行弄清楚它在做什么，而另一部分原因则是它带有一种讽刺、略带调侃的巨蟒剧团（Monty Python）式的态度，|||
brought to coding that I just fell in love with. I mean, it's named, the language is named for Monty Python's Flying Circus. It was not named for the snake. Oh, I never knew that. Did you know that, Patrick? Yeah, I actually did know that, but only because I looked it up. Oh, that's awesome. There's a couple of references to Swallows as well in the, in the documentation online and stuff. So it sort of perpetuates the Monty Python skits through some of the, I don't know how much anymore, but it still does. Yeah.
brought to coding that I just fell in love with. I mean, it's named, the language is named for Monty Python's Flying Circus. It was not named for the snake. Oh, I never knew that. Did you know that, Patrick? Yeah, I actually did know that, but only because I looked it up. Oh, that's awesome. There's a couple of references to Swallows as well in the, in the documentation online and stuff. So it sort of perpetuates the Monty Python skits through some of the, I don't how much anymore, but it still does. Yeah.|||这种态度被带到了编程中，让我一下子爱上了它。我是说，这门语言是因 Monty Python 的《飞行马戏团》（Monty Python's Flying Circus）而命名的。它不是以蛇命名的。哦，我以前从不知道。你知道吗，Patrick？对，我其实知道，但那只是因为我特意去查过。哦，太棒了。在线文档等地方也提到了好几次“燕子”。所以它通过一些……我不知道现在还有多少，但它依然在通过这些方式延续着 Monty Python 的短剧梗。是的。
The spam and eggs are the food and bar used for most of the examples. And then the Python packaging index was originally called cheese shop. So, you know, it's, it, it runs, it runs throughout the release notes,
The spam and eggs are the food and bar used for most of the examples. And then the Python packaging index was originally called cheese shop. So, you know, it's, it, it runs, it runs throughout the release notes,|||“spam”和“鸡蛋”是大多数示例中使用的食物和（变量名）bar。然后，Python 包索引（Python Packaging Index）最初被称为“奶酪店”（cheese shop）。所以，你看，它贯穿于各个版本说明中，
always have a quote from Monty Python or something. So it's, it's, it's deeply engraved in the language for all those people who aren't familiar with Monty Python skits. They're just like, I don't get why you were justifying that it's really, but there,
always have a quote from Monty Python or something. So it's, it, it's deeply engraved in the language for all those people who aren't familiar with Monty Python skits. They're just like, I don't get why you were justifying that it's really, but there,|||总会有一句来自 Monty Python 的引言之类的内容。所以它深深地烙印在这门语言中。对于那些不熟悉 Monty Python 短剧的人来说，他们可能会觉得：我搞不懂你为什么非要为这个辩解，真的。但在这里，
there are various skits throughout time or movie references. So you can look them up later. Some people don't get it. Some people do. I won't judge people. I have already only a few minutes in here. We're only eight minutes in. I've already made two different
there are various skits throughout time or movie references. So you look them up later. Some people don't get it. Some people do. I won't judge people. I have already only a few minutes in here. We're only eight minutes in. I've already made two different|||随着时间的推移，这里有各种短剧或电影梗。所以你可以回头去查查。有些人不懂，有些人懂。我不会去评判别人。我才聊了几分钟啊，我们才开始八分钟，我已经抛出了两个不同的
references to British television. That should tell you a lot about me off the bat. That is true. We also did talk about Doctor Who. You started doing this. You fell in love off the bat. That is true. We also did talk about Dr. Who. Yes. So that you're okay. So you're started doing this. You fell in love with the language. You, you, I don't know. I consider that like a pretty intense thing. Like go on the IRC channel. I don't want to say like, admit, you don't know what you're doing, but I think that takes like a certain bravery. A lot of people would just sort of like continue to Google a few times or, you know, whatever it
references to British television. That should tell you a lot about me off the bat. That is true. We also did talk about Doctor Who. You started doing this. You fell in love off the bat. That is true. We also did talk about Dr. Who. Yes. So that you're okay. So you're started doing this. You fell in love with the language. You, you, I don't know. I consider that like a pretty intense thing. Like go on the IRC channel. I don't want to say like, admit, you don't know what you're doing, but I think that takes like a certain bravery. A lot of people would just sort of like continue to Google a few times or, you know, whatever it|||关于英国电视节目的梗。这在一开始就能让你对我有不少了解了。确实如此。我们之前也聊过《神秘博士》。你开始做这个。你一下子就爱上了。确实如此。我们确实也聊过《神秘博士》。是的。所以你还好吧。所以你开始做这个。你爱上了这门语言。你，你，我不知道。我认为这是一件相当激烈的事情。比如去 IRC 频道。我不想说像是承认自己不知道自己在做什么，但我认为这需要一定的勇气。很多人大概会选择继续多 Google 几次，或者，你知道的，不管怎样，它
wouldn't necessarily own it up and just go online and say, I don't know what I'm doing. Someone helped me. So you went there, you got some help, it sounds like some snark, but some help. And you were able to make progress. So did you end up actually building something at that time in Python, or just kind of experiment with it? Yeah, you know, I was building was building something actually when i got into this in the first place i was trying to build a game and um i was trying to just solve for the initial early problems of of the game like how do we do animation how do we do all these things and so i was i had a prototype that i had built in in dot. And so it was a matter of now trying to replicate that in
wouldn't necessarily own it up and just go online and say, I don't know what I'm doing. Someone helped me. So you went there, got some help, it sounds like some snark, but some help. And you were able to make progress. So did you end up actually building something at that time in Python, or just kind of experiment with it? Yeah, you know, I was building was building something actually when i got into this in the first place i was trying to build a game and um i was trying to just solve for the initial early problems of of the game like how do we do animation how do we do all these things and so i was i had a prototype that i had built in in dot. And so it was a matter of now trying to replicate that in|||未必会大方承认，然后直接上网说：“我不知道自己在做什么，谁来帮帮我。”所以你去了那里，得到了一些帮助——听起来带点讽刺，但也确实得到了帮助——并且你得以取得了进展。那么你当时最终真的用 Python 做出了什么东西，还是仅仅做了一些实验？是的，你知道的，我当时确实在做一些东西。其实我最初接触这个的时候，我是想做一个游戏，嗯……我只是想解决游戏最初期的一些问题，比如我们怎么做动画？我们怎么处理所有这些事情？所以我有一个在 .NET 中构建的原型。所以现在的问题是如何在
Python. And I didn't get as far as I wanted. But that was because at the time, the person who was doing the art for me at the time was using Adobe Flash. And you're really limited in terms of being able to do SVG, you know, play the not SVGs, play those old Flash FLVs and what have you. And really, so that I eventually had to move from that project, had to move over to Adobe Flash itself, only to discover later that they were discontinuing it out from underneath me after selling me the license. Thanks, Adobe. I still will not use their products as a result. But nonetheless, even though I had to switch that project to Flash, I was still building stuff in Python. So I started building just tools and applications,
Python. And I didn't get as far as I wanted. But that was because at the time, the person who was doing the art for me at the time was using Adobe Flash. And you're really limited in terms of being able to do SVG, you know, play the not SVGs, play those old Flash FLVs and what have you. And really, so that I eventually had to move from that project, had to move over to Adobe Flash itself, only to discover later that they were discontinuing it out from underneath me after selling me the license. Thanks, Adobe. I still will not use their products as a result. But nonetheless, even though I had to switch that project to Flash, I was still building stuff in Python. So I started building just tools and applications,|||Python 中复制它。而我没有取得预期的进展。但那是因为当时负责为我做美术的那个人使用的是 Adobe Flash。而且在处理 SVG，你知道的，播放那些不是 SVG 的格式、播放那些老旧的 Flash FLV 等等这方面，你真的会受到很大的限制。说真的，所以我最终不得不离开那个项目，不得不转向 Adobe Flash 本身，结果后来才发现，他们把许可证卖给我之后，居然悄悄把这个产品给停更了。谢谢你啊，Adobe。因此我至今仍然拒绝使用他们的产品。不过尽管如此，尽管我不得不将该项目切换到 Flash，我依然在用 Python 构建东西。所以我开始构建各种工具和应用程序，
trying things out in it, because I enjoyed being able to quickly create a working desktop application that did something, that solved some sort of need that I had. And it's funny because as I gained more experience with other languages like C++ and what have you, I kept hearing people say, oh, you don't use Python for building GUIs. And I just look at them funny. Like, what are you talking about? I do all the time. Because I've built stuff in C++. I've built desktop applications
trying things out in it, because I enjoyed being able to quickly create a working desktop application that did something, that solved some sort of need that I had. And it's funny because as I gained more experience with other languages like C++ and what have you, I kept hearing people say, oh, you don't use Python for building GUIs. And I just look at them funny. Like, what are you talking about? I do all the time. Because I've built stuff in C++. I've built desktop applications|||在其中尝试各种新东西，因为我很享受能够快速创建一个能正常运行的桌面应用程序，它能做点什么，能解决我某种需求的感觉。说来也搞笑，随着我对 C++ 等其他语言有了更多经验，我经常听到有人说：“哦，你不能用 Python 来构建 GUI（图形用户界面）。”我就会用奇怪的眼神看着他们。就好像在说：你在说什么呢？我一直在用好不好。因为我用 C++ 构建过东西。我也在那里构建过桌面应用程序，
there too, or tried. It takes a lot longer. There's a lot more boilerplate. Python, when you know how to use it well, and that's the key, when you know how to use Python well, you can create very maintainable, very performant user experiences in a fraction of the time that you would in other languages. And a lot of that is simply because of the introspective features of the language. Python knows about itself. It knows about its types. It knows about what it is and what it's trying to do as you're working with it. And when you learn to use these patterns,
there too, or tried. It takes a long time. There's a lot more boilerplate. Python, when you know how to use it well, and that's the key, when you know how to use Python well, you can create very maintainable, very performant user experiences in a fraction of the time that you would in other languages. And a lot of that is simply because of the introspective features of the language. Python knows about itself. It knows about its types. It knows about what it is and what it's trying to do as you're working with it. And when you learn to use these patterns,|||或者说尝试过。那要花很长时间。会有更多的样板代码。而 Python，当你懂得如何很好地使用它时——这才是关键——当你懂得如何用好 Python 时，你可以在其他语言所需的一小部分时间里，创造出高可维护性、高性能的用户体验。这很大程度上仅仅是因为该语言的内省（introspection）特性。Python 了解它自己。它了解它的类型。当你使用它时，它了解它自身是什么以及它正试图做什么。当你学会使用这些模式时，
then you don't have to tell the computer as much because it's able to understand itself as it moves forward. I'm kind of misexplaining it. No, I think it makes sense. I think it's a great topic. Maybe we come back to this as far as like introspection, reflection, and how various languages handle this. Maybe we'll put a pin in that one.
then you don't have to tell the computer as much because it's able to understand itself as it moves forward. I'm kind of misexplaining it. No, I think it makes sense. I think it's a great topic. Maybe we come back to this as far as like introspection, reflection, and how various languages handle this. Maybe we'll put a pin in that one.|||你就不需要对计算机交代那么多，因为它在推进的过程中能够理解自身。我可能有点没解释清楚。不，我觉得这说得通。我觉得这是一个很棒的话题。也许我们可以回过头来探讨内省、反射，以及各种语言是如何处理这些机制的。也许我们先把这个话题搁置一下。
I think that might be an interesting topic once we queue it up. But okay, so you're building your game. You're, you know, working all this stuff in Python. By that time, was this like part of your job or had you related the programming into your job or was this still just like a side hobby? At the time, I didn't even have a job because of my disability. I couldn't work because I would have entire days or weeks without warning in which I just could not function.
I think that might be an interesting topic once we queue it up. But okay, so you're building your game. You're, you know, working all this stuff in Python. By that time, was this like part of your job or had you related the programming into your job or was this still just like a side hobby? At the time, I didn't even have a job because of my disability. I couldn't work because I would have entire days or weeks without warning in which I just could not function.|||等我们把这个话题排上日程，它可能会非常有趣。不过好吧，所以你在制作你的游戏。你在用 Python 做所有这些事情。那时候，这算是你工作的一部分吗？或者你已经把编程和你的工作结合起来了，还是这依然只是一个业余爱好？当时我甚至没有工作，因为我的残疾。我无法工作，因为我会毫无预兆地一整天或一整周完全丧失生活自理能力。
So I would just basically focus my attention since I, you know, I had other support. I didn't have to work at the time I focus, I was focusing on my recovery. So every available moment that I had in the, within the confines of a work day, I would be working on building this game or the tooling I needed to build it. And I started about 2013. I realized I knew enough about software engineering at that point to actually run an internship program,
So I would just basically focus my attention since I, you know, I had other support. I didn't have to work at the time I focus, I was focusing on my recovery. So every available moment that I had in the, within the confines of a work day, I would be working on building this game or the tooling I needed to build it. And I started about 2013. I realized I knew enough about software engineering at that point to actually run an internship program,|||所以我基本上把注意力集中在……既然我，你知道的，我有其他的支持。我当时不需要工作，我把精力集中在康复上。因此，在工作日的时间范围内，我拥有的每一个空闲时刻，我都会用来开发这款游戏或构建它所需的工具。我大约从 2013 年开始。我意识到当时我对软件工程的了解已经足够去运行一个实习生项目了，
which I started an open source internship and actually have over a dozen graduates from that too. And most of them have gone on to be themselves senior engineers. And I enjoyed that, being able to also speak life into other people. So I gained all this experience with software engineering, with management, with mentoring, with business analysis, with all these different facets. I had to do everything, DevOps, IT. I was the everything for this organization. Unpaid, but it let me focus all of my energy on it. And then once I got to a point where I could start working, by that point,
which I started an open source internship and actually have over a dozen graduates from that too. And most of them have gone on to be themselves senior engineers. And I enjoyed that, being able to also speak life into other people. So I gained all this experience with software engineering, with management, with mentoring, with business analysis, with all these different facets. I had to do everything, DevOps, IT. I was the everything for this organization. Unpaid, but it let me focus all of my energy on it. And then once I got to a point where I could start working, by that point,|||于是我发起了一个开源实习项目，实际上也有十几位毕业生从该项目毕业。他们大多数后来都成为了高级工程师。我很享受这一点，能够给其他人的人生带来活力与启发。所以我在软件工程、管理、指导、业务分析等各个不同方面积累了所有的这些经验。我不得不什么都做，DevOps、IT。我是这个组织里万能的存在。没有薪水，但这让我能把所有的精力都倾注在上面。然后，一旦我达到了可以开始工作的状态，到那个时候，
I was pretty experienced as an engineer. But it's amazing. A lot of companies just really don't want to hire people with disabilities and they'll find every excuse they can to avoid it because they prefer someone with the it's it's backdoor discrimination it's like well you didn't have an internship at google you don't have a bachelor's of science computer science from this prestigious university you don't have a background that looks like mine therefore you can't possibly be a good engineer and they never stop but consider that the reason I don't is because my background is different. My needs are different.
I was pretty experienced as an engineer. But it's amazing. A lot of companies just really don't want to hire people with disabilities and they'll find every excuse they can to avoid it because they prefer someone with the it's it's backdoor discrimination it's like well you didn't have an internship at google you don't have a bachelor's of science computer science from this prestigious university you don't have a background that looks like mine therefore you can't possibly be a good engineer and they never stop but consider that the reason I don't is because my background is different. My needs are different.|||作为一名工程师，我已经相当有经验了。但令人惊叹的是，许多公司真的不愿意雇佣残疾人，他们会找尽一切借口来逃避，因为他们更倾向于那些拥有……这是一种后门歧视，就像是：“嗯，你没有在谷歌实习过，你没有这所名牌大学的计算机科学理学学士学位，你的背景看起来跟我的不一样，因此你绝不可能是一个优秀的工程师。”他们从不肯停下来想一想，我没有这些的原因是因为我的背景不同。我的需求不同。
And that my experience is just as valid as theirs. But it looks different. And most companies would not consider that. So I spent six years searching for work. And it was getting really discouraging. And then I was finally offered a job at Canonical. And my boss there, when I was going through the interview process, was actually fighting for me. He said, I want him not in spite of his disabilities. I want it because of them, because it gives him a different perspective.
And that my experience is just as valid as theirs. But it looks different. And most companies would not consider that. So I spent six years searching for work. And it was getting really discouraging. And then I was finally offered a job at Canonical. And my boss there, when I was going through the interview process, was actually fighting for me. He said, I want him not in spite of his disabilities. I want it because of them, because it gives him a different perspective.|||而且我的经历和他们的一样有价值。只是看起来不同罢了。大多数公司都不会考虑这一点。所以我花了六年时间找工作。这变得非常令人沮丧。然后我终于得到了 Canonical 的工作机会。我在那里的老板，在我经历面试流程时，实际上在为我争取。他说：“我录用他不是因为忽视他的残疾，而是因为他的残疾。我录用他正是因为这些残疾，因为这赋予了他不同的视角。”
We have a bunch of traditional engineers around here, but this guy's got a different background. That's going to give him a different perspective on problems than we have. And we need that. It was the first time I had actually had someone validate that I had something unique to bring to the table. And that was, his name was Eric. And that was so important to me. So I started my professional journey as a senior software engineer, which is
We have a bunch of traditional engineers around here, but this guy's got a different background. That's going to give him a different perspective on problems than we have. And we need that. It was the first time I had actually had someone validate that I had something unique to bring to the table. And that was, his name was Eric. And that was so important to me. So I started my professional journey as a senior software engineer, which is|||“我们周围有一群传统的工程师，但这家伙有着不同的背景。这会让他对问题拥有与我们不同的视角。而我们需要这一点。”这是我第一次真正遇到有人认可我能带来一些独特的东西。那就是——他叫 Eric。这对我太重要了。所以我以高级软件工程师的身份开始了我的职业之旅，
funny because it means that all the tough stuff that most people are having to get used to when they move into that role was the easy stuff for me. But all the stuff that's easy for everyone else, I hadn't been there for. So I likened it to getting on an airplane from the top of the Empire State Building. You know, you get in, you sit down and turn to the guy going, hey, how did you buckle your seatbelt? Because I wasn't here for that part. Oh, wow. But that's an awesome, encouraging story, though, like the persistence that that must have taken. And, you know, I think that some of those things are right, that it's really tough for people out there who are trying to get into the industry.
funny because it means that all the tough stuff that most people are having to get used to when they move into that role was the easy stuff for me. But all the stuff that's easy for everyone else, I hadn't been there for. So I likened it to getting on an airplane from the top of the Empire State Building. You know, you get in, you sit down and turn to the guy going, hey, how did you buckle your seatbelt? Because I wasn't here for that part. Oh, wow. But that's an awesome, encouraging story, though, like the persistence that that must have taken. And, you know, I think that some of those things are right, that it's really tough for people out there who are trying to get into the industry.|||说来也搞笑，这意味着大多数人在转入这个角色时必须适应的所有困难的事情，对我来说反而是最轻松的部分。但所有对其他人来说轻而易举的事情，我却没经历过。所以我把它比作从帝国大厦顶端直接登上一架飞机。你知道的，你上去，坐下，然后转过头对旁边的人说：“嘿，安全带怎么系？”因为我没经历过前面登机的那部分。哦，哇。不过这是一个非常棒、非常鼓舞人心的故事，这其中一定需要极大的毅力。而且，你知道的，我认为其中有些观点是正确的，对于那些正试图进入这个行业的人来说，确实非常艰难。
You have that persistence is unfortunately needed, but is needed. And so I would say like, you know, that's a great story. And I hope I hope listeners will be encouraged by that as well, that like stick with it and like keep doing it and, you know, going after what you want, because it seems like it seems like you were able to finally find that person who gave you that opportunity and the springboard. Yeah, and you only need one job at the end of the day, at least at any given time. So definitely put yourself out there, interview at a bunch of places and you only need one and then you're in the door. Yeah, And the two rules I set for myself when I was interviewing
You have that persistence is unfortunately needed, but is needed. And so I would say like, you know, that's a great story. And I hope I hope listeners will be encouraged by that as well, that like stick with it and like keep doing it and, you know, going after what you want, because it seems like it seems like you were able to finally find that person who gave you that opportunity and the springboard. Yeah, and you only need one job at the end of the day, at least at any given time. So definitely put yourself out there, interview at a bunch of places and you only need one and then you're in the door. Yeah, And the two rules I set for myself when I was interviewing|||你必须具备这种毅力，虽然这很不幸，但确实需要。所以我想说，这是一个很棒的故事。我希望听众也能从中受到鼓舞，那就是坚持下去，继续努力，去追求你想要的东西，因为看起来……看起来你最终找到了那个给你机会和跳板的人。是的，归根结底，你只需要一份工作，至少在任何特定时间是这样。所以一定要勇敢走出去，去很多地方面试，你只需要成功一次，就能跨进门槛了。是的，我在面试时给自己定下了两条规则，
that I always went back to, and I encourage other people to do this too, is because I was dealing with a lot of the negative feelings of rejection. And so there's two things I would remind myself of. Number one is if you get that initial interview, you're qualified. End of story. Because if you weren't qualified, they wouldn't have taken the time to talk, you're qualified. End of story. Because if you weren't qualified, they wouldn't have taken the time to talk to you at all. It's not a question of whether or not you're qualified. It's a question of whether or not you are bringing the exact skills that they need for that position, because it's a lock and key model. They're not just looking for someone with a pulse, or hopefully not just looking for somebody with a pulse. Most of the time,
that I always went back to, and I encourage other people to do this too, is because I was dealing with a lot of the negative feelings of rejection. And so there's two things I would remind myself of. Number one is if you get that initial interview, you're qualified. End of story. Because if you weren't qualified, they wouldn't have taken the time to talk, you're qualified. End of story. Because if you weren't qualified, they wouldn't have taken the time to talk to you at all. It's not a question of whether or not you're qualified. It's a question of whether or not you are bringing the exact skills that they need for that position, because it's a lock and key model. They're not just looking for someone with a pulse, or hopefully not just looking for somebody with a pulse. Most of the time,|||我一直遵循这些规则，我也鼓励其他人这样做，因为当时我正在应对许多被拒绝带来的负面情绪。所以有两件事我会提醒自己。第一点是，如果你获得了初试机会，说明你是有资格的。就这么简单。因为如果你没有资格，他们根本不会花时间跟你谈，你是有资格的。就这么简单。因为如果你没有资格，他们根本不会花时间跟你交谈。这根本不是你是否具备资格的问题。这是一个你是否带来了该职位所需的确切技能的问题，因为这是一个锁和钥匙（Lock and key）的模型。他们不只是在找一个有呼吸的人，或者希望他们不只是在找一个有呼吸的人。大多数时候，
they're looking for someone with a specific skill set. So if you get that first, and especially if you get like the second or the third interview, if you get rejected after that, in most cases, they're not rejecting you. They're just saying, you know what, you're great. You're good enough to consider for this, but someone else has fits that a little bit better. That's not personal. That's just luck of the draw. The second thing is if you really do slam into discrimination, and I did many times, then that company wasn't worth working for anyway. They don't deserve you. So when they turn you down, their loss, not yours, you wouldn't want to work there because if you're going to get them
they're looking for someone with a specific skill set. So if you get that first, and especially if you get like the second or the third interview, if you get rejected after that, in most cases, they're not rejecting you. They're just saying, you know what, you're great. You're good enough to consider for this, but someone else has fits that a little bit better. That's not personal. That's just luck of the draw. The second thing is if you really do slam into discrimination, and I did many times, then that company wasn't worth working for anyway. They don't deserve you. So when they turn you down, their loss, not yours, you wouldn't want to work there because if you're going to get them|||他们在寻找具备特定技能组合的人。所以如果你得到了第一次面试，特别是如果你得到了第二次或第三次面试，在那之后如果你被拒绝了，在大多数情况下，他们拒绝的不是你。他们只是在说：“你知道吗，你很棒。你足够优秀，可以考虑担任这个职务，但另一个人与这个职位的契合度稍微更好一些。”这不是针对个人的。这纯粹是运气问题。第二点是，如果你真的狠狠撞上了歧视——我经历过很多次——那么这家公司本来就不值得去工作。他们配不上你。所以当他们拒绝你时，是他们的损失，而不是你的，你根本不会想去那里工作，因为如果你会在面试中遭遇这种情况，你在日常工作中也一定会遇到。
the interview, you're going to get it in spades in your day to day. That makes sense. I wanted to clap back to something you said earlier about starting with kind of game development and VBScript and then early Python. So many people start their journey by building games. Patrick, did you start by building games? Like what was your first program? Probably, like it wasn't my sole intent to build games, but yeah, I think it's one of the earliest things I did,
the interview, you're going to get it in spades in your day to day. That makes sense. I wanted to clap back to something you said earlier about starting with kind of game development and VBScript and then early Python. So many people start their journey by building games. Patrick, did you start by building games? Like what was your first program? Probably, like it wasn't my sole intent to build games, but yeah, I think it's one of the earliest things I did,|||这话说得通。我想回应一下你刚才说的关于从游戏开发、VBScript 开始，然后是早期的 Python 的那些事。很多人都是通过制作游戏开启他们的编程之旅的。Patrick，你是一开始就制作游戏吗？比如你的第一个程序是什么？大概吧，虽然制作游戏并不是我唯一的初衷，但对，我认为这是我做的最早的事情之一，
little like question response games yeah absolutely yeah I mean my first program was I mean after you know like printing your name over and over again my first like kind of real thing was I made this arm wrestling game where you had to hit the space bar so many times for a second to
little like question response games yeah absolutely yeah I mean my first program was I mean after you know like printing your name over and over again my first like kind of real thing was I made this arm wrestling game where you had to hit the space bar so many times for a second to|||比如那种问答小游戏。对，完全是这样。我的意思是，我的第一个程序——在经历过诸如一遍又一遍打印你的名字之后——我的第一个比较“真实”的作品是，我制作了一个掰手腕游戏，你必须在几秒钟内疯狂按空格键很多次才能
win an arm wrestling match and my question to you, Jason, is like, you know, why is it, why is games the impetus for so many folks to get into programming? And given that, you know, what does that tell us about, you know,
win an arm wrestling match and my question to you, Jason is like, you know, why is it, why is games the impetus for so many folks to get into programming? And given that, you know, what does that tell us about, you know,|||赢得掰手腕比赛。我给你的问题是，Jason，你知道，为什么……为什么游戏会成为这么多人进入编程领域的契机？鉴于此，你知道，这向我们说明了关于……
getting young people into programming? Well, there's a couple of things. One is, and, you know, having interns for over 10 years and in the context of game development, one thing is that a lot of people get into programming, getting the game development specifically because they view it mistakenly as an extension of playing the game,
getting young people into programming? Well, there's a couple of things. One is, and, you know, having interns for over 10 years and in the context of game development, one thing is that a lot of people get into programming, getting the game development specifically because they view it mistakenly as an extension of playing the game,|||引导年轻人进入编程领域的什么启示？嗯，有几点。第一，你知道的，在拥有超过 10 年的实习生管理经验以及在游戏开发的背景下，有一点是，很多人进入编程领域、特别是进入游戏开发领域，是因为他们误将其视为玩游戏的延伸，
which is a totally different thing. Playing a game and building a game are not even remotely the same thing. And that's a splash of cold water to a lot of people. totally different thing playing a game and building a game are not even remotely the same thing and that's a splash of cold water to a lot of people like oh wow this is not as much fun as i thought it would be i actually wound up talking to one guy who was involved in building um duke nukem and uh he said yeah i actually have never played the game like the original 2d or the modern ones i believe if i'm remembering correctly it was the original 2d and he said you know i never he wrote the physics for it he said i never played the game
which is a totally different thing. Playing a game and building a game are not even remotely the same thing. And that's a splash of cold water to a lot of people. totally different thing playing a game and building a game are not even remotely the same thing and that's a splash of cold water to a lot of people like oh wow this is not as much fun as i thought it would be i actually wound up talking to one guy who was involved in building um duke nukem and uh he said yeah i actually have never played the game like the original 2d or the modern ones i believe if i'm remembering correctly it was the original 2d and he said you know i never|||而这两者完全是两码事。玩游戏和制作游戏简直风马牛不相及。这对很多人来说无异于当头一棒。完全是两码事，玩游戏和制作游戏简直风马牛不相及，这对很多人来说无异于当头一棒，心想：“哦，哇，这可没我想象的那么好玩。”我实际上曾与一个参与制作《毁灭公爵》（Duke Nukem）的人交谈过，嗯……他说：“是的，我其实从来没玩过这款游戏，无论是最初的 2D 版还是现代版。”如果我没记错的话，他说的是最初的 2D 版，他说你知道我从来没……
i never even saw the game i i wrote the physics for it and i have never even i don't even know what the game looks like i never even look bothered to look it up i never played the game it's like so it's it's game development is is itself you know we want to build the game. It's like, so it's, it's game development is, is itself, you know, we, we want to build the game that we want to play. And so that sometimes the impetus of this game doesn't exist. So I'm going to build it for myself. And that's a great way to get started, but it's important to remember that playing and building are two different things. I think the other reason that game development comes up a lot is because it is a good thing for us to put forward as an intro, because game development touches every single facet of software engineering, or at least potentially touches every single facet. Anything that anybody is ever going to write in any code base anywhere has an application in some game.
he wrote the physics for it he said i never played the game i never even saw the game i i wrote the physics for it and i have never even i don't even know what the game looks like i never even looked bothered to look it up i never played the game it's like so it's it's game development is is itself you know we want to build the game. It's like, so it's, it's game development is, is itself, you know, we, we want to build the game that we want to play. And so that sometimes the impetus of this game doesn't exist. So I'm going to build it for myself. And that's a great way to get started, but it's important to remember that playing and building are two different things. I think the other reason that game development comes up a lot is because it is a good thing for us to put forward as an intro, because game development touches every single facet of software engineering, or at least potentially touches every single facet. Anything that anybody is ever going to write in any code base anywhere has an application in some game.|||他为它编写了物理引擎。他说：“我从来没玩过这个游戏，我甚至连看都没看过这个游戏。我为它编写了物理引擎，但我甚至从来没有……我甚至不知道这游戏长什么样，我也懒得去查一下，我从来没玩过这个游戏。”就好像……所以游戏开发本身……你知道的，我们想要制作游戏。就好像，所以游戏开发本身……你知道的，我们想要制作我们自己想玩的游戏。因此，有时候这种游戏的契机并不存在，所以我要为自己制作一个。这是个很好的入门方式，但切记“玩”和“build（构建）”是两码事。我认为游戏开发经常被提及的另一个原因，是因为它是一件非常适合我们拿来作为入门引导的事情，因为游戏开发触及了软件工程的每一个方面，或者说至少潜在触及了每一个方面。任何人在任何地方的任何代码库中编写的任何东西，都在某种游戏中有其应用场景。
So when you're building a game, depending on the nature of the game, when you're building a game, you never know what you're going to need. Pathfinding, search algorithms come up frequently or sorting algorithms. Those matter. Data, data entry, data retrieval. You have save files. How do you render graphics? How do you do sound? How do you do network connections? How do you do all the know, all the way into AI and machine learning? You know, it's all of this could intersect with a game. So games become a very good way of practicing different skills because you need very little excuse to pick up something that you would otherwise have to come up with some really complex and unreachable business need for.
So when you're building a game, depending on the nature of the game, when you're building a game, you never know what you're going to need. Pathfinding, search algorithms come up frequently or sorting algorithms. Those matter. Data, data entry, data retrieval. You have save files. How do you render graphics? How do you do sound? How do you do network connections? How do you do all the know, all the way into AI and machine learning? You know, it's all of this could intersect with a game. So games become a very good way of practicing different skills because you need very little excuse to pick up something that you would otherwise have to come up with some really complex and unreachable business need for.|||所以，当你构建一个游戏时，取决于游戏的性质，当你构建游戏时，你永远不知道你会需要什么。寻路（Pathfinding）、搜索算法经常出现，或者排序算法。这些都很重要。数据、数据输入、数据检索。你有存档文件。你如何渲染图形？你如何处理声音？你如何建立网络连接？你如何做到所有这些，甚至一直延伸到人工智能和机器学习？你知道的，所有这些都可能与游戏产生交集。因此，游戏成为练习各种技能的极佳途径，因为你几乎不需要什么借口，就能去涉猎某些技术——否则的话，你将不得不为之编造一些非常复杂且遥不可及的业务需求。
Yeah, I feel like, you know know one of the interesting things about games it's like uh i equate it to and i love games so i'm gonna say this as somebody who absolutely loves video games but it's it can be kind of an endorphin shortcut or like a serotonin shortcut kind of like eating a jelly donut you know it's like you you get this this really you know intense satisfaction of like you're beating a level of pac-man even though you didn't you didn't practically do anything and and again i love games love love that feeling but i think a lot of people think that they can kind of create they can kind of create that feeling again if they make a game and to your point it's like they could do it
Yeah, I feel like, you know one of the interesting things about games it's like uh i equate it to and i love games so i'm gonna say this as somebody who absolutely loves video games but it's it can be kind of an endorphin shortcut or like a serotonin shortcut kind of like eating a jelly donut you know it's like you you get this this really you know intense satisfaction of like you're beating a level of pac-man even though you didn't you didn't practically do anything and and again i love games love love that feeling but i think a lot of people think that they can kind of create they can kind of create that feeling again if they make a game and to your point it's like they could do it|||是的，我觉得，你知道关于游戏有趣的一点是，我把它等同于——我非常喜欢游戏，所以我以一个绝对热爱电子游戏的人的身份来说这句话——但它可能有点像是内啡肽的捷径，或者血清素的捷径，有点像吃一个果冻甜甜圈，你知道的，就好像你获得了这种非常强烈的满足感，比如你通关了《吃豆人》（Pac-Man）的一个关卡，尽管你实际上什么也没做，而且再说一次，我热爱游戏，非常热爱那种感觉。但我认为很多人以为他们可以通过制作游戏来再次创造这种感觉，按照你的说法，就像他们可以做得更好，
even better but what i've found in the few games that i've made is is um you know when you program the game and you know what you're doing like you know under the hood all the mechanics you know the ai behind the goombas and the turtles and all of that you don't get that same endorphin rush when you beat the level um there's just it's just like uh there's something about the fact that you knew what everything was going to do. You know some people will claim. You could make something so emergent. That you know even you get an endorphin rush.
even better but what i've found in the few games that I've made is is um you know when you program the game and you know what you're doing like you know under the hood all the mechanics you know the ai behind the goombas and the turtles and all of that you don't get that same endorphin rush when you beat the level um there's just it's just like uh there's something about the fact that you knew what everything was going to do. You know some people will claim. You could make something so emergent. That you know even you get an endorphin rush.|||但我在自己制作的少数几款游戏中所发现的是，呃，你知道的，当你对游戏进行编程并且你知道自己在做什么时——比如你知道底层的全套机制，你知道板栗仔（goombas）和乌龟背后的 AI 以及所有这些——当你通关时，你不会获得那种相同的内啡肽冲动，呃，这只是……这就像是，因为你早就知道每个东西会做什么，所以那种感觉……你知道，有些人会声称，你可以做出如此具有涌现性（emergent）的东西，以至于你甚至能在通关自己的游戏时获得内啡肽冲动。
When you beat your own game. I'm not saying that's impossible. But I think as a. As a first level game designer. For a first time game designer. It's almost impossible. And so that's a trap. That a lot of people fall
When you beat your own game. I'm not saying that's impossible. But I think as a. As a first level game designer. For a first time game designer. It's almost impossible. And so that's a trap. That a lot of people fall|||我并不是说这绝对不可能。但我认为，作为一个初级游戏设计师，对于一个第一次做游戏的设计师来说，这几乎是不可能的。所以这是一个很多人都会掉进去的陷阱，
into is is they make the game and they think they're making it for themselves but it's never actually going to be satisfying for you to solve your own puzzle you're not going to get that same rush and and so you really have to build it for other people but but it is interesting that that that it's ubiquitous i mean every almost maybe, 90 percent of the people I talk to got into programming from wanting to make a game. And I just think there's there's something really fascinating about that. Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, I will put a caveat. There are some occasions where building your own game can give you that.
into is is they make the game and they think they're making it for themselves but it's never actually going to be satisfying for you to solve your own puzzle you're not going to get that same rush and and so you really have to build it for other people but but it is interesting that that that it's ubiquitous i mean every almost maybe, 90 percent of the people I talk to got into programming from wanting to make a game. And I just think there's there's something really fascinating about that. Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, I will put a caveat. There are some occasions where building your own game can give you that.|||那就是他们制作游戏，以为自己是在为自己制作，但解决你自己的谜题实际上永远不会让你感到满足，你不会获得那种同样的快感，所以你真的必须为其他人制作游戏。但有趣的是，这太普遍了——我的意思是，几乎我交谈过的 90% 的人都是因为想制作游戏而进入编程领域的。我只是觉得这其中有一些非常迷人的地方。是的，完全如此。而且，你知道的，我要加个前提。在某些情况下，构建你自己的游戏确实能给你带来那种感觉。
I mean, Marcus Person loved Minecraft. You know, he built the game he wanted and he enjoyed it. And, you know, I've built a couple of games where I genuinely enjoyed playing them, you know, when I was done. But I guess the thing is, is that in both cases, you're not just building to scratch a personal itch, but also to build something
I mean, Marcus Person loved Minecraft. You know, he built the game he wanted and he enjoyed it. And, you know, I've built a couple of games where I genuinely enjoyed playing them, you know, when I was done. But I guess the thing is, is that in both cases, you're not just building to scratch a personal itch, but also to build something|||我是说，Marcus Persson（我的世界之父）热爱《我的世界》。你知道，他构建了他想要的游戏并乐在其中。而且，你知道的，我也制作过几款游戏，做完之后我确实由衷地喜欢玩它们。但我想问题在于，在这两种情况下，你不仅仅是为了止痒（满足个人癖好），也是为了构建某些
that you think other people are going to enjoy. And so that, well, it's the same thing with writing because I'm also an author, obviously, as you mentioned, but I also write fiction and yes, I write books for me,
that you think other people are going to enjoy. And so that, well, it's the same thing with writing because I'm also an author, obviously, as you mentioned, but I also write fiction and yes, I write books for me,|||你认为其他人也会喜欢的东西。所以，嗯，写作也是如此，因为正如你所提到的，我显然也是一位作家，但我也会写小说，是的，我为自己写书，
but I don't write books just for me. I'm writing a story that I think is going to mean something to someone else. And I was talking with someone recently and I said, you know, it's writing the book for yourself is how you get started. Writing the book for someone else is how you finish. Because if you're not writing it for someone else, you're not going to have the impetus or the motivation to stick with them through the editing and the revision and the, you know, on and on and on the treadmill of actually
but I don't write books just for me. I'm writing a story that I think is going to mean something to someone else. And I was talking with someone recently and I said, you know, it's writing the book for yourself is how you get started. Writing the book for someone else is how you finish. Because if you're not writing it for someone else, you're not going to have the impetus or the motivation to stick with them through the editing and the revision and the, you know, on and on and on the treadmill of actually|||但我写书不单单是为了我自己。我正在写一个我认为会对其他人有意义的故事。我最近和一个人聊天时说，你知道的，为自己写书是让你得以开始的方式。为别人写书则是让你得以完成的方式。因为如果你不是为了别人而写，你将没有动力或动机在编辑、修改以及无休无止的……
finishing the book. The passion for creating a story that's going to mean something to someone else is what's going to get you over that, line and i think the same can be true of software in general i mean if you look at the people who are happiest in in our industry they're the people who are building something they genuinely believe in uh if you don't believe in what you're building it can be really hard to generate that passion because it's like well i'm doing this for a paycheck but i'm really just doing this for someone else's bottom line but when you focus it line of, maybe this is why user stories help. You focus it in lines of, I'm solving this so that this person can do this thing, then it becomes important, then it becomes valuable. And that creates that motivation to keep going.
finishing the book. The passion for creating a story that's going to mean something to someone else is what's going to get you over that, line and i think the same can be true of software in general i mean if you look at the people who are happiest in in our industry they're the people who are building something they genuinely believe in uh if you don't believe in what you're building it can be really hard to generate that passion because it's like well i'm doing this for a paycheck but i'm really just doing this for someone else's bottom line but when you focus it line of, maybe this is why user stories help. You focus it in lines of, I'm solving this so that this person can do this thing, then it becomes important, then it becomes valuable. And that creates that motivation to keep going.|||完成这本书的“跑步机”中坚持下去。对创作一个对他人有意义的故事的热情，才是能让你越过终点线的东西。我认为软件开发通常也是如此。我的意思是，如果你看看我们行业中最快乐的人，他们都是在构建他们真正坚信的东西。呃，如果你不相信你正在构建的东西，要产生这种热情会非常困难，因为这就像是：好吧，我做这个是为了薪水，但我其实只是在为别人的利润底线打工。但当你把它聚焦于——也许这就是为什么用户故事（user stories）很有用——当你把它聚焦于“我正在解决这个问题，以便这个人能够做这件事”时，它就变得重要了，它就变得有价值了。这创造了继续前进的动力。
I think this is like a great conversation and not to dwell here so we can keep going on, but I'll say, I think not to say that you're wrong, but I'll slightly disagree. So I've had that argument. And I think what you're saying is, is a very common, common approach where for a lot of people, it is absolutely true to be able to, I want to say ship something. If I phrase it in another way, people say it and actually see the thing come out, actually understand why you're doing it. I find for like, as just a personal, as myself, that, that isn't the only thing or even a very important thing for me.
I think this is like a great conversation and not to dwell here so we can keep going on, but I'll say, I think not to say that you're wrong, but I'll slightly disagree. So I've that argument. And I think what you're saying is, is a very common, common approach where for a lot of people, it is absolutely true to be able to, I want to say ship something. If I phrase it in another way, people say it and actually see the thing come out, actually understand why you're doing it. I find for like, as just a personal, as myself, that, that isn't the only thing or even a very important thing for me.|||我觉得这是一场很棒的对话，为了不在此过多纠缠以便我们继续往下聊，但我会说——倒不是说你错了，但我会略有不同意。所以我经历过这种争论。我认为你所说的是一种非常、非常普遍的方法，对许多人来说，能够……我想说是“交付（ship）”某样东西，这绝对是千真万确的。如果我换个方式表达，人们常说要把它做出来并实际看到成果，真正理解你为什么要这样做。但我发现，就我个人而言，这并不是唯一的事情，对我来说甚至不是非常重要的事情。
I've at times worked on stuff I actually thought was dumb or would never work or wasn't that useful. But the specific problem that I was there to solve and the people there to solve it, I saw that there was growth to be had. I saw that there was something I could learn. There was some way I could kick the ball for it. and often taking those things and leveraging them into the next thing. Right. And so those things aren't of infinite, you know, like a lifespan, you know, you kind of got to go in with a mission and learn something. But I'll say, I think what you were to, I guess,
I've at times worked on stuff I actually thought was dumb or would never work or wasn't that useful. But the specific problem that I was there to solve and the people there to solve it, I saw that there was growth to be had. I saw that there was something I could learn. There was some way I could kick the ball for. and often taking those things and leveraging them into the next thing. Right. And so those things aren't of infinite, you know, like a lifespan, you know, you kind of got to go in with a mission and learn something. But I'll say, I think what you were to, I guess,|||我有时会参与一些我其实觉得很蠢、绝不会起作用或者没那么有用的东西。但我去解决的具体问题以及在那里一起解决问题的人，让我看到了成长的空间。我看到了有我可以学习的东西。有某种我可以把球踢得更远的方式。而且往往是把这些东西拿来利用，并将其转化为下一件事情的跳板。没错。所以这些东西并不是无限期的，你知道的，比如它的生命周期，你得带着使命进去并学到一些东西。但我要说，我认为你刚才所表达的，我猜，
back up my point, since I'm making a contrary point is like to back up what you're saying about, you know, finishing off a book or finishing off a game. Oftentimes, that first 80% is really appealing. And the last 20% of, you know, the game's completion takes as long or longer and is really hard and it's drudgery. And you need a certain motivation to get through it. But I don't want to like discourage people that if you get through that 80%, and then you don't finish, you got to be careful doing that only or always or if you're in a startup. But just as like a learning experience, you can learn a lot from that first 80%. You can learn a lot more or the same from the last 20%, but there is value to be had there. And so going through unfinished game after unfinished game is also something you see happen from a lot of people who end up releasing independent titles
back up my point, since I'm making a contrary point is like to back up what you're saying about, you know, finishing off a book or finishing off a game. Oftentimes, that first 80% is really appealing. And the last 20% of, you know, the game's completion takes as long or longer and is really hard and it's drudgery. And you need a certain motivation to get through it. But I don't want to like discourage people that if you get through that 80%, and then you don't finish, you got to be careful doing that only or always or if you're in a startup. But just as like a learning experience, you can learn a lot from that first 80%. You can learn a lot more or the same from the last 20%, but there is value to be had there. And so going through unfinished game after unfinished game is also something you see happen from a lot of people who end up releasing independent titles|||为了支持我的观点——既然我持相反观点——就像是支撑你刚才说的关于完成一本书或完成一个游戏一样。通常，前 80% 的过程真的非常吸引人。而最后 20% 的游戏完成阶段，耗时同样长甚至更久，而且非常艰难，是一项苦差事。你需要某种动力才能挺过去。但我不想打击大家，如果你挺过了那 80%，然后没有完成，你在只这样做、总是这样做、或者身处创业公司时可得小心了。但仅作为一种学习体验，你可以从那前 80% 中学到很多东西。你可以从最后 20% 中学到更多或同样多的东西，但那里确实存在价值。因此，经历一个又一个未完成的游戏，也是你在许多最终发布独立游戏作品的人身上经常看到的情况，
that sort of that, you know, four or five failed things that they made sure to learn something from it. And so I'll say that, yes, but like, just a caution out there, I think there are different flavors of folks. And when I interviewed people for my work, talking about, hey, is it a motivating driving factor for you to ship something? Or are you okay going through a number of like failed attempts at stuff and potentially never shipping? Will that motivate or deep? Well, it doesn't only motivate people. Is that going to demotivate you?
that sort of that, you know, four or five failed things that they made sure to learn something from it. And so I'll say that, yes, but like, just a caution out there, I think there are different flavors of folks. And when I interviewed people for my work, talking about, hey, is it a motivating driving factor for you to ship something? Or are you okay going through a number of like failed attempts at stuff and potentially never shipping? Will that motivate or deep? Well, it doesn't only motivate people. Is that going to demotivate you?|||也就是他们做了四五件失败的事情，并确保从中吸取了教训。所以我想说，是的，但是——只是提出一个警告——我认为人们有不同的风格。当我在工作中面试别人时，我会讨论：“嘿，交付某样东西对你来说是一个激励驱动因素吗？还是说你能够接受经历多次失败的尝试并且可能永远不会交付？这会激励你还是会……？”好吧，这不仅仅是激励人们的问题。这会打击你的积极性吗？
And it's an introspective question. I think a lot of people have to answer and aren't very thoughtful about. Most people haven't sat down and thought, do I need to ship or am I okay? Right. And to clarify what I'm saying, I'm saying that the motivation needed to ship is extrinsic. That's what I'm specifically referring to. Not that the motivation to do it is extrinsic, but the motivation to ship it. That 80%, to your point, that 80% can be intrinsic, but it's very difficult to get the intrinsic motivation all the way through that extrinsic motivation has to kick in to get you over the hump in most cases.
And it's an introspective question. I think a lot of people have to answer and aren't very thoughtful about. Most people haven't sat down and thought, do I need to ship or am I okay? Right. And to clarify what I'm saying, I'm saying that the motivation needed to ship is extrinsic. That's what I'm specifically referring to. Not that the motivation to do it is extrinsic, but the motivation to ship it. That 80%, to your point, that 80% can be intrinsic, but it's very difficult to get the intrinsic motivation all the way through that extrinsic motivation has to kick in to get you over the hump in most cases.|||这是一个需要内省的问题。我认为很多人必须回答这个问题，但并没有经过深思熟虑。大多数人并没有坐下来想过：我需要交付吗，还是说我无所谓？没错。为了澄清我的观点，我说的是，交付所需的动机是外在的。这正是我所特指的。并不是说做事本身的动机是外在的，而是说“交付”它的动机是外在的。正如你所说的那样，那 80% 可以是内在驱动的，但仅靠内在动机很难支撑全过程，在大多数情况下，外在动机必须发挥作用才能帮你跨过这道坎。
So you need, you need a mixture of both. If it's all extrinsic, you won't get started. If it's all intrinsic, you won't finish. And that's okay. If you like, like to your point, it's okay. If you don't finish it, i've got a million unfinished projects that i will never know um you know learning from things is learning from things is great but it it really is that it really is that extrinsic motivation that that drives you like okay you know what this is this is now really tough but i want to get this in someone else's hands and that's that's what gets it over the line. Yep.
So you need, you need a mixture of both. If it's all extrinsic, you won't get started. If it's all intrinsic, you won't finish. And that's okay. If you like, like to your point, it's okay. If you don't finish it, i've got a million unfinished projects that i will never know um you know learning from things is learning from things is great but it it really is that it really is that extrinsic motivation that that drives you like okay you know what this is this is now really tough but i want to get this in someone else's hands and that's that's what gets it over the line. Yep.|||所以你需要两者的结合。如果全是外在动机，你根本不会开始；如果全是内在动机，你将无法完成。这没关系。如果你喜欢……正如你所说的那样，没完成也没关系。我有一百万个永远不会完成的项目，我甚至不知道……你知道的，从事情中学习固然很好，但真正驱动你的是那种外在动机，就像：“好吧，你知道吗，现在这真的很艰难，但我很想把这个交到别人手中。”这就是让它跨越终点线的东西。是的。
So one thing I was thinking about related to the motivation question is, you know, and Patrick, you might be a little different on this, but on my side, I've used a zillion different languages and I haven't felt particularly attached to any of them. And I don't really see, you know, I just kind of feel like, well, for this particular context, you know, for example, I'm on a microprocessor. And so it's just a lot easier to use C or, you know, I'm building in Unity. And so it's just a lot easier to use C sharp, right? And so I'll just use whatever. But in your case, you know know you have spent a ton of time and energy on python um you know reading through as you said uh in the pre-show you know the documentation many many
So one thing I was thinking about related to the motivation question is, you know, and Patrick, you might be a little different on this, but on my side, I've used a zillion different languages and I haven't felt particularly attached to any of them. And I don't really see, you know, I just kind of feel like, well, for this particular context, you know, for example, I'm on a microprocessor. And so it's just a lot easier to use C or, you know, I'm building in Unity. And so it's just a lot easier to use C sharp, right? And so I'll just use whatever. But in your case, you know know you have spent a ton of time and energy on python um you know reading through as you said uh in the pre-show you know the documentation many many|||所以关于动机问题，我想到的一件事是——Patrick，在这方面你可能有点不同——但在我这边，我用过无数种不同的语言，而且我对它们都没有什么特别的依恋。我真的不觉得……我只是觉得，好吧，对于这个特定的场景，比如，我在一个微处理器上编程，所以使用 C 语言要容易得多，或者，你知道的，我正在用 Unity 构建，所以使用 C# 要容易得多，对吧？所以我用什么都行。但在你身上，你知道你花了大把的时间和精力在 Python 上，呃，正如你在节目开始前所说的那样，你把文档读了一遍又一遍，
times over and and so my question is you know what you know like like in the context of all these different languages and everything what kept drawing you to python and what caused you to dive so deeply into python what what what really is the impetus for that ironically extrinsic motivation i um i logged into that python irc room and i never left and i became a regular in the room. I say never left in the, you know. Sure. I log out at bedtime. You know, there were a couple of times I wasn't online at all. But like in general, like this, it's been the core of if I'm involved in the Python community or any programming community, that's it.
所以我的问题是，你知道，在所有这些不同的语言和一切的背景下，是什么一直吸引你走向 Python，又是什么促使你如此深入地钻研 Python？这背后的真正动力到底是什么？具有讽刺意味的是，是外在动机。我，嗯，我登录了那个 Python IRC 聊天室，就再也没有离开过，并成了那里的常客。我说的“从未离开过”，你知道的。当然，我在睡觉时会登出。你知道的，有几次我根本没上线。但总的来说，就像这样，如果我参与了 Python 社区或任何编程社区，核心就是这个。
That's where you're going to find me. It's going to be on IRC. And I kept seeing the same questions showing up again and again and again. And I just began thinking, it's worth documenting at that point, if only to save myself the work of having to repeat the entire answer all over again. So I began writing a series of articles that was just attempting to document some of this tougher to understand stuff in Python. And the number one problem I saw with people coming into Python was they were bringing with it the assumptions from their language of origin. And this is, I would say, why most people get frustrated with Python is they're not writing Python for Python like someone who starts in the language fresh would. They're writing Python as C++ or as Java or as Ruby or as JavaScript or whatever. And it becomes a very frustrating exercise
这就是你会找到我的地方。我就会在 IRC 上。我一直看到同样的问题一遍又一遍地出现。我开始觉得，在这个时候把它们记录下来是值得的，哪怕只是为了省去自己必须把整个答案重新复述一遍的工作。于是我开始写一系列文章，只是试图记录 Python 中一些比较难以理解的东西。我发现人们进入 Python 时遇到的头号问题是，他们带来了自己原本掌握的语言的假设。我想说，这就是为什么大多数人会对 Python 感到沮丧：他们并没有像一个刚接触这门语言的新手那样为 Python 写 Python 代码。他们把 Python 当成 C++、Java、Ruby、JavaScript 或其他什么语言来写。这就变成了一次非常令人沮丧的练习。
to write Python code when you're trying to apply the patterns and the thought processes of another language because Python is very different in how it solves problems. And those differences are the reason why it is so easy to build a complete solution in a short span of time. But those
当你试图应用另一种语言的模式和思维过程时，编写 Python 代码会变得非常痛苦，因为 Python 解决问题的方式非常不同。这些差异正是它能在短时间内构建出完整解决方案的原因。但这些
advantages become stumbling blocks when you don't know they're there, or you don't fully understand them. So what I began doing is explaining these core concepts. And I just thought, you know, it's just some post up on dev, big deal. Until I got a message in chat one day and someone said, did you look at the Android news feed? I'm like, I never look at the news feed. I don't know why. He said, you're on it. Like, wait, what? My article series had gone viral for just a flash in the pan moment of about two days.
优势在你不知道它们存在，或者没有完全理解它们时，就会变成绊脚石。所以我开始做的是解释这些核心概念。我当时想，这不过是在 Dev 网站上发几篇帖子罢了，没什么大不了的。直到有一天我在聊天中收到一条消息，有人说：“你看 Android 新闻动态了吗？”我说：“我从不看新闻动态。我不知道为什么。”他说：“你上头了。”我说：“等等，什么？”我的系列文章居然病毒式传播了，像昙花一现一样火了两天。
It was it was it was trending. I'm like, wait, how did that? Wait, let's let's dive into that. So where was this hosted and how did that virality happen? Do you have any insight? I have no clue. So this was on dev.to
它当时正在热门趋势上。我说：“等等，这怎么……”等等，让我们深入探讨一下。那么这发布在哪里？这种病毒式传播是如何发生的？你有什么见解吗？我毫无头绪。所以这是在 dev.to 上发布的。
and I had a number of followers on there just from that was where I was doing all my tech writing. And I would just write things down and my somewhat snarky and I guess almost irreverent way of approaching certain things in coding just caught people's attention. They enjoyed it. So for some reason or another, for reasons I don't fully understand, those articles took off. And I wish I could crack the code and say why, but most virility online is just chance yeah and anyway but i
我在那里有很多粉丝，因为那就是我进行所有技术写作的地方。我会把一些东西写下来，我对编程中某些事情的这种略带讽刺、甚至可以说是近乎大不敬的处理方式吸引了人们的注意力。他们很喜欢。所以由于某种原因，出于我并不完全理解的原因，那些文章火了。我希望我能破解其中的密码并说出原因，但网上的大多数病毒式传播都只是运气，无论如何，但我
realized this is there's something here so at the time i was talking with a publisher that was wanting me to do this this um you know video course on c++ and i wound up like turning it down but um around that time i started thinking like, I'm now being approached by publishers. I wonder if NoStarch would take this. And so I pitched the article series to them and said, I think I can turn this into a book. And Bill Pollack took one look at it. He said, I think you're right. And within a week, I had a book contract for Dead Simple Python.
意识到这里面大有文章。当时我正在跟一个出版商谈，他们想让我做这个，这个，嗯，你知道的，关于 C++ 的视频课程，我最后拒绝了。但，嗯，大约在那个时候我开始想，我现在有出版商来找我了。我想知道 NoStarch（无淀粉出版社）会不会接受这个。于是我把那系列文章推介给他们，说我或许能把它变成一本书。比尔·波拉克（Bill Pollack）看了一眼，就说：“我觉得你说得对。”一周之内，我就签下了一份关于《极简 Python》（Dead Simple Python）的书籍合同。
So I just began starting out like, I'm just going to translate these articles. But see, here's the trick. I started out just defining the things that I kept seeing, meeting, explaining. But it was more scattershot. It's like, okay, this, this, this, this. But I'm a very systematic individual. When I start writing the book, I'm like, all right, let's start from first concepts and go through. But I don't want to drag anyone through that same.
所以我一开始的想法很简单，我只是要把这些文章翻译一下。但看，这里的诀窍在于：我最初只是在定义那些我不断看到、遇到、解释的东西。但它更像是散弹式的。就像是，好吧，这个、这个、这个、这个。但我是一个非常系统化的人。当我开始写这本书时，我想，好吧，让我们从第一性原理开始，然后一路推导下去。但我不想把任何人拖进那种老套路里。
This is a variable, boys and girls. You're coming from another language, you don't want that basic explanation again. So it was a, let's start from first concepts without beating over the head with programming 101 again. And which turns out no one else has done, at least not for Python. And I start, so I start going through it and as i get about two-thirds of the way through the book i realize i don't understand half of this stuff and i'm going this is weird so i i go to the documentation and i start digging into the inner workings of the language and by time i so i went from being a mediocre Python programmer at the beginning of it, just trying to document some basic things. By the time I was at the end of it, I was a literal expert in the language. And my technical editors were four of the top guys in the Python room who were answering everyone's questions.
各位大男孩和小女孩们，这就是变量。如果你是从其他语言转过来的，你肯定不想再看那种基础解释了。所以这是一次尝试：从第一性原理开始，而不会再次对你进行编程 101 的狂轰滥炸。事实证明，还没有其他人这样做过，至少对 Python 来说是这样。然后我开始，所以我开始通读它，当写到这本书的三分之二左右时，我意识到我自己其实有一半的东西根本不懂，我心想，这太奇怪了。于是我去看官方文档，开始深入研究这门语言的内部运作。到了最后——所以我在写这本书之初只是一个平庸的 Python 程序员，只想记录一些基本的东西。等写到最后时，我已经成了这门语言的字面意义上的专家。我的技术编辑是 Python 聊天室里最顶尖的四个人，他们平时负责回答所有人的问题。
These are super smart guys, experts in the language, really, really practiced. And they're going through and they're going, yep, you got it. I'm like, I've actually done it. I've actually mastered Python in the process of writing a book. If you want to learn something inside out, write a book. If you also don't want to do anything for four years of your life, write a book. You know, I love this dichotomy because, because,, I think, and I are a little bit similar in line on this. Both of us are not particularly social with respect to like developer communities and all of that. We have the podcast, love the podcast, love the listeners. We try and provide as much content as we can. But I'm not like, I've never really been into to, like, I've been on IRC like two or
这些都是超级聪明的人，是这门语言的专家，经验极其丰富。他们通读了全书，然后说：“没问题，你写对了。”我心想：我真的做到了。我在写书的过程中真正精通了 Python。如果你想把某样东西学得透彻，就去写本书。如果你还想让你的生活中四年时间什么也干不成，那就去写本书。你知道，我非常喜欢这种二分法，因为，因为，我觉得，你和我都有一点相似之处。我们俩对开发者社区以及诸如此类的社交活动其实都不是特别热衷。我们有播客，热爱播客，热爱听众。我们尽量提供尽可能多的内容。但我并不是那种……我其实从来没有真正融入过……我上 IRC 大概也就两、
three times because people asked me to go on and I just couldn't stick with it. And so I think there's two, like, you know, kind of, we have two different ways to both achieve our goals. You know, in my case, at least, you know, it's more like, you know, I would set kind of a goal for myself. I would try my best to hack my way through it. And then what I would find, I mean, an example I keep going back to is I didn't know Python. I hadn't even heard of Python, but I wanted to make a board game engine. So I wanted to make an engine upon which I would make new board games. I'd conceptualized, but, you, but I was having a hard time. The incremental cost of coding up these board games in C or C++ is getting really expensive.
三次吧，因为别人让我上去，但我实在坚持不下来。所以我想，我们有两条不同的途径来实现各自的目标。至少在我的情况下，你知道，更像是，你知道的，我会为自己设定某种目标。我会尽最大努力通过不断瞎折腾来解决它。然后我发现——我一直提起的一个例子是——我不懂 Python。我甚至都没听说过 Python，但我想做一个棋盘游戏引擎。所以我想做一个引擎，在这个引擎之上我可以制作新的棋盘游戏。我都已经构思好了，但是，你知道，我遇到了困难。用 C 或 C++ 编写这些棋盘游戏的增量成本变得实在是太高了。
So I thought, I'll make this board game engine. But because it's an engine and people can do whatever, they can create their own units and types and dice and everything it needed to be very open ended so i thought oh i'll just have a variant which is the c++ object that could be anything it could be an int or a double or a string could be anything and then i'll just have one class which is a map of variant to variant and so this is super open-ended. It could kind of do anything. And after, I want to say months of this, I mean, it was part-time. I still had my day job. But after months of this, I did a little bit of background reading. I realized I'd invented the most janky version of Python ever. And so what I should have done is just used Python. And, and so I think that's,
所以我想，我要制作这个棋盘游戏引擎。但因为这是一个引擎，人们可以做任何事情，他们可以创建自己的单位、类型、骰子以及所有东西，所以它必须非常开放。于是我想，哦，我会搞一个变体（variant），这是一个可以代表任何东西的 C++ 对象，它可以是一个整型、一个双精度浮点数或一个字符串，什么都可以。然后我只需要一个类，它是一个从变体到变体的映射（map）。所以这个结构超级开放。它基本上能做任何事情。经过——我想说这花了几个月的时间，当然这是业余时间做的，我还有正职工作。但在几个月之后，我做了一些背景阅读。我意识到，我发明了史上最垃圾版本的 Python。所以我当时应该做的事其实是直接使用 Python。而且，所以我觉得，
that's something where you can kind of go too extreme on just trying to do things yourself, based off your own first principles, you know, now on the other side of it, you know, you, you want to also kind of, as Patrick was saying, you know, take, take pride and take accomplishment and take solace if you need to in your own achievements personally, regardless of what the world outside is doing. So there's this place of good balance where you, you know, in your case, Jason, you, you saw this need, you, uh, you know, address the need, you kind of iterated on that and you were kind of constantly in communication with your audience and that built up to writing this book and i think it's just a phenomenal story and i
这就是那种你会在“纯粹靠自己、基于自己的第一性原理去解决问题”这件事上走向极端的情况。你知道，现在站在事情的另一面，正如帕特里克（Patrick）所说，你也希望为自己个人的成就感到骄傲、有成就感，并在需要时从中获得慰藉，而不管外部世界在做什么。所以这里存在一个很好的平衡点，你知道，就你的情况而言，杰森（Jason），你看到了这个需求，你，嗯，你知道的，满足了这个需求，你对它进行了迭代，并且你与受众保持着持续的沟通，最终积累成了这本书的诞生。我觉得这是一个非常了不起的故事，我
think the put a bookmark exclamation on this and land the play now i think there's there's different ways of kind of achieving what you want and as long as you kind of you know work hard persevere and continue to iterate um you know you'll eventually be able to learn any language or, or, or, you know, pursue any of these, these goals that you have out there. Yeah. Yeah. I would, I would agree. Um, and I often like to say, I hate, there's two phrases I hate. Actually, there's three phrases I hate in programming. I hate the term best practices because there's no such thing. There's good practices,
觉得可以用一个书签式的感叹号来为这段话收尾并尘埃落定。现在我认为，实现目标的方式有很多种，只要你努力工作、坚持不懈并不断迭代，嗯，你最终将能够学会任何语言，或者，或者，或者，你知道的，追求你所拥有的任何这些目标。是的。是的，我同意。嗯，我经常喜欢说，我讨厌，我有两个讨厌的短语。实际上，在编程中有三个短语是我讨厌的。我讨厌“最佳实践”这个词，因为根本没有这种东西。只有好的实践，
but there's no objective best because no two projects are exactly the same and best practice here doesn't apply over there. So best practices is very kind of, it has a connotation of a sort of arrogance about it. It's like, well, you know, I know the best way to do this. It's like, well, I know the best way to do this.
但没有客观上的“最佳”，因为没有两个项目是完全相同的，这里的最佳实践并不能套用到那边。所以“最佳实践”这种说法，带有一种傲慢的意味。这就好比：“嗯，我知道怎么做才是最好的。”这就好比：“嗯，我知道怎么做才是最好的。”
It's like, no, you know the best way to do that in this project. So I don't like the term best practice. I prefer good practices. Because it should be a dialogue. There should always be dialogue about it. Why do we do it this way? The second term I hate is yagney. You aren't going to need it.
这就像是，不，你只知道在这个项目中怎样做才是最好的。所以我不喜欢“最佳实践”这个词。我更喜欢“好的实践”。因为这应该是一个对话。关于这一点，应该永远存在对话：我们为什么要这样做？我讨厌的第二个词是 YAGNI（你不会需要它）。
True, you don't want to pile things on early on but you want to think about where do you want to go with this thing and not code yourself into a corner like like you were mentioning with you know the different types you recognize early on that you were going to regardless of the direction you went and you recognize early on that you were going to you wanted to have that flexibility and And so you start making those decisions around that flexibility. You're not necessarily implementing all the flexibility right off the bat, but you're not making any decisions that are going to block you. And the third thing I hate is don't reinvent the wheel. Because we reinvent the wheel all the time.
确实，你不想在早期堆砌太多东西，但你需要思考：你希望这个东西最终走向何方？不要把自己逼进死胡同，就像你刚才提到的那些不同的类型一样。你很早就意识到，无论你朝哪个方向发展，你都希望拥有这种灵活性。所以你开始围绕这种灵活性做出那些决策。你可能不会在一开始就把所有的灵活性都实现出来，但你不会做出任何会堵死你后路的决定。我讨厌的第三个件事是“不要重复造轮子”。因为我们无时无刻不在重复造轮子。
We reinvent the wheel every day. How many variations of the wheel, the literal physical wheel, do we actually have in the world? And sometimes you can learn some of the best things from building something that already exists, building it again yourself. You can learn a ton from that process, even if you don't use it. And sometimes you build it and you go, oh, I'm actually sitting on something that's right brilliant. And if you fall into one of the kind of the 90% of situations where it's not, hey, you now understand that thing pretty well. Yeah, definitely. So I'll segue from Jason's map of variant to variant and to the conversation I put a pin in earlier. I'll pop the back up here, which is we talked about that you were mentioning the introspection.
我们每天都在重复造轮子。世界上究竟有多少种轮子的变体——字面意义上的物理轮子？有时，通过构建已经存在的东西、自己重新构建一次，你可以学到一些最好的东西。你可以从这个过程中学到大量的知识，即使你最终并没有使用它。有时你造出来之后会发现：“哦，我其实掌握了一个相当绝妙的东西。”如果你落入那 90% 的并非如此的情况中——嘿，你现在对那项技术的理解也已经相当透彻了。是的，绝对如此。所以，我将从杰森的“变体到变体的映射”过渡到我之前搁置一旁的话题。我把它重新拿出来，也就是我们刚才讨论的关于内省（introspection）的特性。
I said the word reflectivity. Yeah. But you mentioned this about one of the things that captured sort of your attention in Python. We've also loosely tangentially referenced sort of dynamic typing and sort of like you were asking, how do you define a data structure? So we're sort of bouncing around some set of topics here that I'm going to try to squish together arbitrarily.
我当时说的是反射性（reflectivity）。是的。但你提到了这是吸引你关注 Python 的特性之一。我们刚才也若即若离地提到了动态类型，以及你刚才问的：如何定义数据结构？所以我们在这里探讨了一组话题，我将试图把它们随意地捏合在一起。
And, you know, let us talk about here, which is you were mentioning one of the things people do in Python that holds them up from loving Python is not doing Python Python, but doing something else in Python. And there are some languages, I guess, that pride themselves on being able to do whatever in that style. But, you know, you made this contention. I don't know, but I'll say maybe this is one of them. This, you know, sort of assuming that everything should be super strongly statically typed up front. You know, everything is compiled, time known, all of this. Maybe that that's part of why. If not, then, oh, well, you can tell me I'm wrong and then we can talk about it anyways but you know i'll i'll tee that up but where are your thoughts i guess in that
你知道，让我们在这里谈谈这个：你提到人们在 Python 中做的事情之一，阻碍了他们爱上 Python 的原因，是没有用 Python 的方式写 Python，而是在 Python 里写别的东西。我想，有些语言以能够在那种风格下做任何事情而自豪。但是，你知道，你提出了这样一个论点。我不知道，但我会说也许这就是其中之一。这种，你知道的，认为万物在最初都应该具有超级强烈的静态类型的假设。你知道，一切都是编译时已知的，诸如此baz。也许这就是原因的一部分。如果不是的话，那好吧，你可以告诉我我错了，然后我们无论如何都可以讨论它，不过你知道的，我会抛出这个话题，你对那个领域有什么看法呢？
space yeah well i want to briefly say that every language has its thing capital t thing trade we will put a little t and one little trademark symbol after it every language has its thing and once you understand what the thing is then you can get a pretty good handle on the language. Just to kind of frame this, C Sharp's thing is inversion of control. C++'s thing is memory management. Rust's thing is borrowing. Ruby's thing is lack of parentheses.
是的，嗯，我想简短地说，每一种语言都有它的“杀手锏”——大写 T 的“杀手锏”（Thing）。我们在它后面加上一个小写的 t 和一个微型商标符号。每一种语言都有它的杀手锏，一旦你明白了它的杀手锏是什么，你就能对这门语言有相当好的掌控。为了给这个概念做个铺垫：C# 的杀手锏是控制反转（inversion of control）。C++ 的杀手锏是内存管理。Rust 的杀手锏是借用（borrowing）。Ruby 的杀手锏是缺少括号。
I'm serious. That's what they hung everything on. And it's like, if you had to write a list of every feature of the language, which thing are they going to put list of every feature of the language, which thing are they going to put at the absolute top of the list and say, this is first and foremost, this is what we're not compromising on. Every language has that one thing about it.
我是认真的。这就是他们把一切都悬挂其上的核心。这就好比，如果你必须写一份该语言所有特性的列表，他们会把哪一个特性放在列表的最顶端，并宣称：“这是首要的、绝对不妥协的核心。”每一种语言都有这样独一无二的特质。
And Python's thing is introspection. That is that at any time you can look under the hood, you can look inside of something and you can see it working. You can see what's there and you can then maybe rewire it too. And this is one of the reasons why Python is so cool because you can write a class that tightly integrates with every feature of the data model,
而 Python 的杀手锏就是内省（introspection）。这就是：在任何时候，你都可以掀开引擎盖，查看某个内部的东西，看它是如何运作的。你可以看到里面有什么，然后你甚至还可以对它进行重新布线。这就是 Python 如此酷炫的原因之一，因为你可以编写一个类，与数据模型的每一个特性、
every feature of the language. And it acts as a native type. You can make it so tightly coupled that the usage is just completely obvious. And that's one of the neat things about it. But the way it's able to do that is because it's exposing all of these what are called Dunder methods, double underscore methods, that are how python makes that object work with different parts of the language operators and what have you and it's not just your data type it's not just your classes that do this it's all the classes that do this to some degree or another with an asterisk there because there's some really deep internals and integers that get interesting but but I'm not going there. But you have this ability to kind of dive down into the internals of anything.
与语言的每一个特性都紧密集成。并且它表现得就像一个原生类型。你可以让它们紧密耦合，使得它的用法完全显而易见。这是它很酷的特点之一。但它之所以能够做到这一点，是因为它暴露了所有这些所谓的“双下划线方法”（Dunder methods，即双下划线方法），正是通过这些方法，Python 才让该对象与语言的不同部分、运算符等协同工作。而且这不仅仅适用于你的数据类型，不仅仅是你的类能做到这一点，所有的类都在某种程度上能做到这一点（这里加个星号，因为有一些非常深层的内部机制和整数处理起来很有趣，但我不会扯到那儿去）。但你确实拥有这种能力，可以深入到任何东西的内部去一探究竟。
And this is Python's thing, that introspective, you can see, you can examine, and you can change anything. And that is oftentimes surprising for people who are used to data hiding. So if you're coming from C++, you're coming from Java, you're used to hiding your internals, locking everything away. You've got the gate, the dog and the guard. And then you've got these nice little getters and setters or what have you. And you're carefully controlling, you know, everything that comes in and everything that goes out. So in Python, you'll still write getters and setters and what have you, but you're not actually stopping anyone from examining the internals, which by the way, makes testing a lot easier.
这就是 Python 的杀手锏——这种内省能力，你可以看到、检查并且改变任何东西。对于习惯了数据隐藏的人来说，这往往是令人惊讶的。因此，如果你来自 C++ 背景，或者来自 Java 背景，你习惯了隐藏内部细节，把一切都锁起来。你有了大门、看门狗和警卫。然后你有了这些漂亮的取值器和设值器（getters and setters）之类的东西。你小心翼翼地控制着所有进出的东西。所以在 Python 中，你仍然会编写取值器、设值器之类的方法，但你并没有真正阻止任何人去检查内部结构——顺便说一句，这使得测试变得容易得多。
But rewinding a little bit to just touching on that whole dynamic typing thing, Python's way of working with variables is very different from other languages. So Python has people fling around the phrase Python doesn't have variables, which is not exactly true. But variables are not one thing in Python. It's two things that work together. You have a name and you have a value.
不过，稍微倒回一点，触及到整个动态类型的话题，Python 处理变量的方式与其他语言非常不同。因此，Python 社区里流传着这样一句话：“Python 没有变量。”这其实并不完全准确。但在 Python 中，变量并非单一的东西，而是由协同工作的两部分组成：你有一个名字（name）和一个值（value）。
So a name has this, the name itself has a scope, but it has no type. It's a loosely bound language. So you create a name and it's scoped to wherever you define inside your function, inside your class, whatever. Actually class isn't a scope. Inside your module. But you have a name and it's scoped somewhere. Then you have a value, and that value sits in memory, and that value does not have a scope. You can access that value from anywhere, theoretically, but it has to be bound to a name. So you create a binding. When you're doing an assignment in Python, you're creating a binding
所以，名字本身有一个作用域（scope），但没有类型。这是一门弱绑定语言。因此，你创建一个名字，它的作用域是你定义它的地方——在你的函数内部、在你的类内部，诸如此类（实际上类并不是一个作用域，而是在你的模块内部）。但你有一个名字，它在某处拥有作用域。然后你有一个值，这个值存在于内存中，并且这个值没有作用域。理论上你可以从任何地方访问这个值，但它必须被绑定到一个名字上。所以你创建了一个绑定。当你在 Python 中进行赋值时，你正在创建一个绑定，
between this value in memory and this name. And where this becomes important, by the way, that value, that does have a type and it does have a strict type. You can't change the type of the value. If it's a string, it's a string. This is not JavaScript. You can't compare a string and a number and get a value. It's just going to go, what are you doing? Why are you doing this to me?
介于内存中的这个值和这个名字之间。顺便说一句，这个地方很重要：那个值，它确实有一个类型，而且是一个严格的类型。你不能改变值的类型。如果它是一个字符串，它就是个字符串。这不是 JavaScript。你不能把一个字符串和一个数字相加并得到一个值。它只会对你说：“你在干什么？你为什么要对我这样做？”
You're being irrational. JavaScript will just let you. So a value has a type, but it has no scope a name has a scope but no type and where this becomes really helpful is that anytime you do any form of assignment or any sort of passing like even passing to um a parameter and a function what you're really doing is you're binding that name to the same value in memory that the other name pointed to. So if I say foo equals five, I'm creating a value five in memory. I'm drawing a line from that to the word foo. And then I say bar equals foo. I'm not drawing a line between foo and bar. I am drawing a line
你太不理智了。但 JavaScript 就会直接容忍你这样做。所以，一个值有类型，但没有作用域；而一个名字有作用域，但没有类型。这种机制真正派上用场的地方在于：无论你在什么时候进行任何形式的赋值，或者进行任何类型的参数传递（比如传递给函数的某个参数），你真正做的事情是：把那个名字绑定到内存中另一个名字所指向的同一个值上。所以，如果我说 `foo = 5`，我在内存中创建了一个值 5。我画了一条线，从那个值连向单词 `foo`。然后我说 `bar = foo`。我并不是在 `foo` 和 `bar` 之间画线。我是在画一条线，
between bar and the same value in memory that foo pointed to. Then you have to understand that with the exception of strings, integers, and booleans, and floats, outside of those, and tuples, everything else is mutable. It can be changed, which means if you've bound two names to the same list in memory, or the same dictionary, which would be a hash map for those of you coming from Java. If you bind two names to the same value, then it doesn't matter which name you use to change that value. When you change that value, the mutated or changed value is visible from both names. This is surprising to people at first
介于 `bar` 和 `foo` 刚才指向的内存中的同一个值之间。然后你必须明白，除了字符串、整数、布尔值和浮点数之外——除了这些和元组（tuple）之外，其他所有东西都是可变的（mutable）。它们是可以被改变的。这意味着，如果你把两个名字绑定到内存中的同一个列表（list），或者同一个字典（对于来自 Java 阵营的人来说，这就相当于哈希映射 Hash Map）上，如果你把两个名字绑定到同一个值，那么无论你使用哪个名字去修改那个值都无所谓。当你修改那个值时，被突变或修改后的值通过这两个名字都是可见的。这起初会让人们感到惊讶，
because you expect to pass in a list and you modify the list and wait, what happened? The original list got changed. Yes, because you're just just rebinding that's all you're doing and then you then you're changing the list but this is why python is used so often for data science is because you can pass in something like a numpy array this huge just ungodly half a gig of data array and it doesn't matter how many times you pass it around. You have one copy of memory. And as long as you get used to that sort of thought process that I'm not
因为你期望传入一个列表，然后你修改了列表，结果——等等，发生什么了？原始列表被修改了。是的，因为你只是在重新绑定，这就是你所做的一切，然后你修改了列表。但这就是为什么 Python 经常被用于数据科学的原因，因为你可以传入诸如 NumPy 数组这样巨大的、足足半个吉字节的庞大数据数组，而无论你把它传递了多少次，在内存中都只有一份拷贝。只要你习惯了这种思维过程——即我在赋值时并不是在
making a copy when I'm doing assignment, I am rebinding. I'm creating an alias to this thing. Once you get that into your system as how this works, then it becomes a lot easier to write code where it's got a smaller memory footprint. You're not making extra copies of things because things are just, it's the same thing being passed around. And it becomes a lot easier to write long chains of functions that are processing something than in a language that would be like C++, where you've got to think about, am I passing by reference? Am I passing by value? Am I passing by pointer? And you have to think about all the semantics. You don't have to think about the semantics in Python once you're used to that idea of rebinding. Yeah. One of the things that I think, you know, the introspection really
创建拷贝，而是在进行重新绑定，我只是在为这个东西创建一个别名。一旦你将这种运作机制融入到你的系统思维中，编写内存占用更小的代码就会变得容易得多。你不会创建额外的东西拷贝，因为传递的始终是同一个东西。而且，编写一连串处理某事的函数链，也会比在 C++ 这样的语言中变得容易得多——在 C++ 中，你必须考虑：我是按引用传递？按值传递？还是按指针传递？你必须考虑所有的语义。一旦你习惯了重新绑定这个理念，你在 Python 中就不需要考虑这些语义了。是的。我认为内省真正教给人们的一件事是——
teaches people, whether they're going to stick with Python or, you know, just use it and move on to another language is, you know, the ability to like have a deep connection between data and code. So imagine you're reading a YAML file or an XML file or JSON file or something into your program, you know, you can in Python, because it's dynamically typed, because of all the introspection, you can read in a YAML file that has, you know, a name category and the name category has a first name category and that first name category is bob and then when you read that file in and in python you can just say you know print my file dot names dot first name you'll get bob and so it's because you know python is just creating that structure automatically and it's
无论他们是会坚持使用 Python，还是只是使用它然后转向另一种语言——那就是能够在数据和代码之间建立深厚联系的能力。想象一下，你正在将一个 YAML 文件、XML 文件、JSON 文件或类似的东西读入你的程序，在 Python 中，由于它是动态类型的，由于所有的内省机制，你可以读入一个 YAML 文件，其中包含一个名称类别（name category），而这个名称类别又包含一个名字类别（first name category），并且这个名字的第一类别是“鲍勃”（bob）。然后当你把那个文件读入 Python 后，你只需说：“打印我的文件点 names 点 first name”，你就会得到“鲍勃”。这是因为 Python 正在自动创建该结构，
not something statically typed like c++ where you have to pre-define what you expect this JSON file is going to do. And so if you do something like read JSON in C++, it tends to get kind of ugly where it's going to read everything into dictionaries where you can't say what is the type of this object because you're past that point. C++ can't easily do kind of like runtime type inference type stuff. Right. It becomes very complicated. Yeah. You know, this idea of like, I have my data,
这不像 C++ 那样需要静态类型，在 C++ 中你必须预先定义你期望这个 JSON 文件具有的结构。因此，如果你在 C++ 中做类似读取 JSON 的事情，往往会变得有点丑陋，因为你需要把所有东西都读入字典中，而在那之后你无法断言这个对象的类型是什么，因为你已经过了那个阶段。C++ 无法轻易做到类似于运行时类型推断之类的事情。没错。这变得非常复杂。是的。你知道，这种“我拥有我的数据，
my code is kind of driven by my data. The way you realize that stuff in C++ is through things like protocol buffers, where you run this command and it generates a zillion lines of C++ that have a whole bunch of types in there. But, you know, I think seeing Python shows you kind of, you know, if you're willing to make sacrifices in other areas, like this is like just such a beautiful way
我的代码是由我的数据驱动的”的理念，你在 C++ 中实现它的方式通常是通过协议缓冲区（protocol buffers）之类的东西，你运行一个命令，它就会生成数百万行的 C++ 代码，里面包含一大堆类型。但是，你知道，我认为看到 Python 展示了，如果你愿意在其他领域做出牺牲，这简直是一种如此美妙的方式，
for, you know, working with data and code together. And I think that's one of the reasons I think why data scientists tend to really jump on, another reason why they tend to jump on Python. Yeah, it's a very data-first language. And again, it still cares about those types. I think this is part of what makes it work. It's not saying that the type isn't important, but it's changing the focus from what is the particular framing of that data, like C++ cares about not just does it have this structure, but is it actually in the instance of this exact class that I've written? Whereas in Python, you have instead what's referred to as duck typing.
可以让数据和代码协同工作。我认为这也是为什么数据科学人员倾向于真正投奔 Python 的原因之一，这是又一个原因。是的，这是一门非常以数据为先的语言。而且再次说明，它仍然关心这些类型。我认为这正是让它起作用的一部分原因。它并不是说类型不重要，而是它改变了焦点：数据的特定框架是什么？例如，C++ 不仅关心它是否具有这种结构，还关心它是否真的是我编写的这个确切类的实例？而在 Python 中，你拥有的是被称为“鸭子类型”（duck typing）的东西。
If it looks like a duck and quacks like a duck, it's a duck. And Python doesn't really care whether it's a duck or a moose in a duck suit. If it can fit the basic criteria, then that is if it can fit the assumptions that you're making about the nature of the data, then you can work with it as if
如果它看起来像一只鸭子，叫起来像一只鸭子，那么它就是一只鸭子。Python 并不真正在乎它到底是一只鸭子还是一头穿着鸭子服的驼鹿。如果它能符合基本标准，也就是说，如果它能符合你对数据本质所做的假设，那么你就可以把它当作
it is that data um and so you start seeing like there there is inheritance in python there is believe it or not you can even do like one of the things people ask when they come into python is can i do an overloaded you know can i do an overloaded function the handles you know and the the easy answer is no and the true answer is no. And the true answer is yes, you actually can. There is a way to do overload. They're called single dispatch functions in Python, and you can do them. And I talk about them in the book. But it's not based on it is this class. It's based on it can do these things. And so you start being able to write your type checking type logic, not around being an instance of a thing, but having certain criteria.
那种数据来处理。因此你会发现——Python 中其实有继承机制。信不信由你，你甚至可以做到……人们进入 Python 时会问的问题之一是：“我可以编写一个重载函数吗？一个能够处理……的重载函数？”简单的回答是“不能”，真实的回答也是“不能”。真实的回答是“其实可以”。确实有一种方法可以做到重载。它们在 Python 中被称为单分派函数（single dispatch functions），你可以使用它们。我在书里探讨过它们。但这并不是基于“它是这个类”，而是基于“它能做这些事情”。因此，你开始能够编写你的类型检查逻辑，不是围绕着“它是某个东西的实例”，而是围绕着“它具备某些特定的标准”。
And there's these cool things called abstract base classes where you can describe what you're expecting out of the data instead. It needs to be iterable or it needs to be numeric or whatever. You know, there's all these different abstract base classes. And those are based on certain behavior being implemented on the type, not on the type itself. And so that's one of the reasons why it can be very quick to write some very complex code, because you can work with that on the basis of what it does, not what it is. Yeah, that makes a bunch of sense.
这里有一些很酷的东西，叫做抽象基类（abstract base classes），你可以用它们来描述你对数据的期望。它需要是可迭代的（iterable），或者需要是数值型的（numeric），诸如此类。你知道，有各种各样不同的抽象基类。这些都是基于在类型上实现了某种特定的行为，而不是基于类型本身。因此，这也是为什么编写一些非常复杂的代码会非常快的原因之一，因为你可以根据它的“所作所为”而不是根据它的“本质是什么”来与它交互。是的，这非常合乎情理。
I wanted to pivot a little bit here. One thing that is sort of like a staple of Python or is relatively famous or infamous at Python is the GIL. The GIL is the Global Interpreter Lock. And so the idea here, and actually JavaScript has the same thing. I don't know why Python gets so beat up for this. But the idea with the GIL is, if you say, I'll just kind of tee it up. If you say, you know, X equals two in Python, Python will, you know, before the way it will process that instruction is it will claim a mutex.
我想在这里稍微转换一下话题。Python 的一个标志性特征，或者在 Python 中相对著名或“声名狼藉”的东西，就是 GIL。GIL 是全局解释器锁（Global Interpreter Lock）。所以这里的理念是——实际上 JavaScript 也有类似的东西，我不知道为什么 Python 要因此挨这么多骂。但 GIL 的核心理念是——我先做个铺垫——如果你在 Python 中说 `x = 2`，Python 会在处理这条指令之前，先申请一个互斥锁（mutex）。
That's a global mutex across your entire python program it'll lock that it'll say nobody else can run any instructions right now it'll do the x equals to assignment and then it'll release that lock and so now if you have another thread in the same process it's executing Python now that other thread has the opportunity to do something. But at any given time for a process, only one instruction can get executed other than there are some exceptions, which we should definitely talk about. But what's your take on that whole paradigm? And I heard that there's talk of them getting rid of it.
这是贯穿你整个 Python 程序的全局互斥锁。它会锁定这个锁，并宣告：“现在其他任何人都不准运行任何指令。”然后它会执行 `x = 2` 的赋值，接着释放这个锁。所以现在，如果你在同一个进程中有另一个线程正在执行 Python，那么这个其他线程现在有机会做点事情了。但在任何给定时间，对于一个进程来说，除了某些我们绝对应该讨论的例外情况之外，只能执行一条指令。但你对这种整体范式有什么看法？我听说有传言说他们打算摆脱它。
What's going on there well so the the gil definitely gets a bad rap unfairly so i need to i need to touch on the history of the attempts to remove it there have been multiple attempts now as of right now it is now possible to compile Python without the GIL. They do have that, but you have to compile it yourself. There's some caveats to it I'm not going to go into, but there have been other attempts to remove the GIL. And the funny thing is that it always has a negative impact on performance. But even that aside, the GIL actually does contribute some sanity because I'm going to back way up to first concepts here. Concurrency and parallelism are terms that we use interchangeably.
那里的情况是怎么样的？嗯，所以 GIL 确实名声不太好，而且这种名声是不公平的，所以我需要谈谈历史上试图移除它的几次尝试。现在已经有了多次尝试，截至目前，实际上已经可以不用 GIL 来编译 Python 了。他们确实有这个功能，但你必须自己编译它。这其中有一些需要注意的细节，我不会展开细讲，但以前也有过其他试图移除 GIL 的尝试。有趣的是，这总是会对性能产生负面影响。但即便抛开这一点不谈，GIL 实际上确实贡献了一定程度的理性，因为我要把话题远远地拉回第一性原理。并发（concurrency）和并行（parallelism）是我们经常混用的两个术语。
And we should not be using them interchangeably because they're not even remotely the same thing. Concurrency means that while I'm waiting on one thing, I do something else. Parallelism means I'm doing two things at once. Now, the reason we tend to confuse these two things are because in many languages that are not, that don't have something similar to the GIL, threading is a way to achieve parallelism because those threads could split off into multiple CPUs. They're not guaranteed to split off into separate CPUs,
我们不应该把它们混为一谈，因为它们甚至连遥远的相似之处都没有。并发意味着：当我在等待一件事的同时，我去做另一件事。并行意味着：我同时在做两件事。现在，我们之所以倾向于把这两件事混淆，是因为在许多没有类似 GIL 机制的语言中，线程（threading）是实现并行的一种方式，因为这些线程可以分流到多个 CPU 上。它们并不保证一定能分流到独立的 CPU 上，
but they might. So the way threading tends to work in many languages then kind of bleeds those two concepts together, but you're actually doing two different things. So concurrency is needed in the context of IO blocking. And this is where I am waiting on an input from the user. And so while I'm waiting on that user input or that network connection or whatever, I am I.O. blocked. I can't do anything about that. I'm just waiting for someone else to say, hi, I'm here now. While I'm waiting, I'm going to be doing something. I'm going to be running some heavy calculations or whatever. What this is doing is it's improving the perceived responsiveness of your program. Your code's not actually faster, but what's happening is that
但它们可能会。因此，在许多语言中，线程的运作方式往往会将这两个概念融为一体，但实际上你做的是两件不同的事情。所以，并发是在 I/O 阻塞的背景下需要的。这就是我正在等待来自用户的输入的时候。因此，当我等待那个用户输入、或者等待那个网络连接、或者无论什么情况时，我都处于 I/O 阻塞状态。我对此外无能为力，我只是在等待别人说：“嗨，我现在到了。”在我等待的同时，我要去做点别的。我要去运行一些沉重的计算或者其他什么。这样做的好处是，它改善了你的程序被感知到的响应能力。你的代码并没有真的变快，但发生的情况是，
because you're doing something while you're waiting, it appears to be faster because while that user was typing, some of those calculations are going on in the background. And this is crucial when you're doing UX design because you're spending a lot of time waiting on the user to click on something, so you can do other stuff in the background meanwhile. That's concurrency. Parallelism is where you're trying to actually speed up some sort of super heavy thing, like, say, a very complex mathematical calculation, by having multiple CPUs work on it at a time.
因为你在等待的同时做了一些事情，所以它显得更快了，因为当那个用户在打字时，后台正在进行一些计算。这在进行 UX（用户体验）设计时至关重要，因为你要花大量时间等待用户点击某些东西，以便你同时能够在后台做其他事情。这就是并发。并行则是指你试图通过让多个 CPU 同时工作，来实际加速某种超级繁重的事情，比如，非常复杂的数学计算。
One CPU can only do one thing at a time, and it's going to actually put one thing on hold to run a separate instruction, and it'll typically be keeping multiple balls in the air at a time. It just switches so fast that we never notice that it's just like the human brain. We don't actually multitask. We just context switch rapidly. That's all we're actually doing. CPU is doing the same thing. But when you have multiple CPU cores in a machine, then you can do multiple things at once because CPU one is doing one thing. CPU two is doing a different thing. That's parallelism because you actually have two CPUs working for you at the same time. That is useful for CPU block things where the thing that's holding you back is how long it's taking to actually do the math or what have you.
一个 CPU 在同一时间只能做一件事，它实际上会把一件事挂起去运行另一条独立的指令，并且它通常会同时抛着好几个球。它切换得如此之快，以至于我们永远不会注意到它——就像人脑一样。我们其实并没有真正多任务处理。我们只是在快速地进行上下文切换。这就是我们真正在做的事情。CPU 也是如此。但是，当机器中有多个 CPU 核心时，你就可以同时做多件事情，因为 CPU 1 在做一件事，CPU 2 在做另一件事。这才是并行，因为你确实有两个 CPU 同时为你工作。这对于 CPU 阻塞的事情很有用，因为阻碍你的因素正是进行数学计算等操作所花费的时间。
So Python has tools for both of these things, even with the GIO in place. You have asynchrony, which is a Python controlled form of concurrency. And you have traditional threading, which is an operating system controlled form of concurrency. And it has both of these tools to handle the IO blocking. Similarly, it has a module which gets a lot of unfairly bad rap called multiprocessing that allows you to spin up multiple Python processes to be able to handle different things you want to do at the same time. Now, that's actually a good thing because multiprocessing has, in any language, a significant amount of overhead. When you add more threads,
因此，Python 针对这两种情况都提供了工具，即使在 GIL 存在的情况下也是如此。你有异步（asynchrony），这是一种由 Python 控制的并发形式；你也有传统的线程（threading），这是一种由操作系统控制的并发形式。它拥有这两种工具来处理 I/O 阻塞。同样，它拥有一个经常受到不公平恶评的模块，叫做多进程（multiprocessing），它允许你启动多个 Python 进程，以便能够同时处理你想做的不同事情。现在，这其实是一件好事，因为在任何语言中，多进程都有相当大的开销。当你添加更多的线程、
more processes, what you're actually doing is you are increasing the load on the machine to actually manage this. So the overhead of managing multiple threads and processes has a cost itself on performance. And when you get into it, this is not something you just throw at code and make it faster. You have to actually weigh the cost of managing those multiple threads or those multiple processes against the benefits to your code. And that requires a fair bit of experimentation. So because Python separates these two things out, then you can use the lighter things, asynchrony or threads, for IO blocking. And then when you actually encounter a situation where parallelism is probably going to speed up your code, then you can pull that off the shelf and bring it in in a deliberate fashion using only just as many processes or workers as necessary to actually speed up your code. Funny thing is you would think more workers faster, but in most cases, two or three workers
更多的进程时，你实际在做的事情是：你正在增加机器管理这些东西的负载。因此，管理多个线程和进程的开销本身就会对性能造成成本。当你深入研究时，这并不是那种你可以随便扔给代码就能让它变快的东西。你必须实际权衡管理这些多线程或多进程的成本，与它们为你带来的代码性能提升之间的利弊。这需要相当多的实验。因此，由于 Python 将这两者分离开来，你可以对 I/O 阻塞使用较轻量的工具——异步或线程；而当你真正遇到并行可能会加速代码的情况时，你就可以把它从工具箱里拿出来，以一种审慎的方式引入，只使用实际加速代码所需的尽可能少量的进程或工作线程（workers）。有趣的是，你可能会认为工作线程越多越好、速度越快，但在大多数情况下，两到三个工作线程
is all you're ever going to need. Bringing in 10, 20 workers is actually going to slow you way, way down. So there's all these things. And so the GIL I, is beneficial because it forces you to do this thinking up front. And you have to start thinking about how do I share data between these things? How do I get messages back and forth? in every language, like locking and deadlocking and live locking and the consumer producer problem. And you are forced by Python's GIL to solve these problems deliberately upfront in your design. So when you actually implement it, you have less surprises, not no surprises, less surprises. So that's my view on the GIL. And it is possible now to get rid of it, but I don't really see any need to in those cases. But if you get rid of it, then how do they handle all those things that you just mentioned? What if two different threads, say one says X equals two and the other says X equals three you know without a gil how did how did they deal with that and i would have to say i don't know that there is a reason why it has
正是你所需要的全部。引入 10 个或 20 个工作线程实际上会大大拖慢你的速度。所以有各种各样的情况。因此，GIL 是有益的，因为它迫使你在前期进行这种思考。你必须开始思考：我如何在这些事物之间共享数据？我如何来回发送消息？在每种语言中，比如锁机制、死锁、活锁以及生产者消费者问题。而 Python 的 GIL 迫使你在设计之初就深思熟虑地解决这些问题。因此，当你真正实现它时，你会减少意外，不是没有意外，而是减少意外。这就是我对 GIL 的看法。现在摆脱它是有可能的，但在那种情况下我真的看不到任何必要。但如果你摆脱了它，他们又该如何处理你刚才提到的那些所有问题呢？如果两个不同的线程，比如一个说 X 等于 2，另一个说 X 等于 3，你知道，如果没有 GIL，他们是如何处理这个问题的呢？我不得不说，我不知道有什么理由它已经
taken them a decade to figure out how to get it out of python we know van rossum is directly involved in it and it's very experimental right now so the stability and sustainability of it are completely all i know is they just is we don't just announce that they figured out how to get rid of it but i think you know to your point like there's there's something really there's a fundamental problem here which is you fundamentally can't do two things at the same time to the same object and have a deterministic program. And so it's almost like a PR thing. It's like we got rid of the GIL because it's such bad PR.
花了一个十年才弄清楚如何把它从 Python 中移除。我们知道范·罗斯姆（Guido van Rossum）直接参与其中，而且它现在非常实验性，所以它的稳定性和可持续性完全是……我只知道他们刚刚……我们不能只是宣布他们弄清楚了如何摆脱它，但我认为正如你所说，这里有一个真正根本性的问题，那就是你从根本上无法对同一个对象同时做两件事情，还能得到一个确定性的程序。所以这几乎就像是一个公关事件。就像我们摆脱了 GIL 是因为它作为公关太糟糕了。
But we're not going to reverse gravity or anything here. So there's still a lock at some point. Yeah, and it's still on by default like if you download python 311 right now or python 312 uh beta and compile it it's going to have the gil you have to actually pass a specific flag and the idea is it's one of my technical editors had a saying if you know why you're not supposed to stick a fork in a toaster, then you're qualified to stick a fork in a toaster. And my best guess is it's something along those lines. If you know why you should be getting rid of the GIL, then you're qualified to compile Python without the GIL.
但我们在这里不会逆转引力什么的。所以在某个地方仍然有一个锁。是的，而且默认情况下它仍然是开启的，如果你现在下载 Python 3.11 或 Python 3.12 测试版并进行编译，它就会带有 GIL。你必须实际传递一个特定的标志，其理念是——我的一个技术编辑曾说过一句名言：“如果你知道为什么不应该把叉子插进烤面包机里，那你就有资格把叉子插进烤面包机。”我最好的猜测是，这与此类似。如果你知道为什么要摆脱 GIL，那么你就有资格在没有 GIL 的情况下编译 Python。
And you're going to be prepared to handle all of the consequences of trying to actually do the compilation. If compiling Python in the first place is a scary thought to you you probably shouldn't be trimming off the gil because yeah it's a good point you know i think a good a good analogy here is um is is udp versus tcp you know in a sense like tcp this is for sending things over the network you know the way tcp works is i send some bytes over the network and the other person receives some bytes and it just all you know shows up in order and if the bytes don't get there tcp will like retry and they'll handle it all for you so i know lots of
并且你将准备好应对尝试实际进行编译的所有后果。如果一开始编译 Python 对你来说是一个可怕的想法，你可能就不应该剔除 GIL，因为是的，这是一个很好的观点。你知道，我认为这里有一个很好的类比，那就是 UDP 与 TCP。从某种意义上说，TCP，这是用于在网络上传输数据的，你知道，TCP 的工作方式是我在网络上发送一些字节，另一个人接收一些字节，然后你知道，它们都会按顺序出现，如果字节没有到达，TCP 会进行重试，并且会为你处理好一切，所以我知道很多
acknowledgements and inquiries did you get it yes i get it i'm sending the next piece okay go in and send it i got it all right good lots of back and forth yes exactly and so when i read you know 16 bytes from somebody else over a tcp socket i know they're in order i don't have to think about it and the people are using udp you know are doing it because they understand tcp they have a very specific thing that they need to solve maybe sending video and and it doesn't work as well with the latency of tcp and they're kind of they're using udp knowing all the limitations and writing their own user space kind of workarounds for them so it sounds like the same same kind of thing here and the whole the whole reason that gil's gotten bad rap anyway is because people have been looking for a scapegoat for why
确认和查询。你收到了吗？是的，我收到了。我正在发送下一块。好的，进去发送吧。我收到了，很好。大量的来回交流。是的，完全是这样。所以当我通过 TCP 套接字从别人那里读取 16 个字节时，我知道它们是有序的，我不需要考虑它。而使用 UDP 的人之所以这样做，是因为他们了解 TCP，他们有需要解决的非常具体的问题，也许是发送视频，而这与 TCP 的延迟不太契合，他们使用 UDP 是在了解所有局限性的情况下，为自己编写用户空间的变通方法。所以听起来这里也是同样的情况，而且 GIL 遭到恶评的整个原因无论如何都是因为人们一直在寻找替罪羊，来解释为什么
python is so stinking slow which is one of the main reasons why people have disliked it historically. Is it has been slow. And there's been all these reasons. And what it came down to is just implementation. Because it is now, I think, don't quote me on this. I would have to look it up again. But I think I remember something along the lines of is since python 3 uh 3.8 it is now 30 times faster it is at this point approaching java in terms of performance um so and this is
Python 如此讨厌的慢，这也是历史上人们不喜欢它的主要原因之一。那就是它一直很慢。并且有所有这些原因。归根结底只是实现问题。因为现在，我想——别把这话当作绝对真理，我得重新查证一下。但我记得大概是这样的：自从 Python 3.8 以来，它现在快了 30 倍，在性能方面，它在此时已经接近 Java 了。所以这仅仅是
just from work that we know and um uh some other developers and microsoft's put a lot of money into this as well um into funding the speeding up of Python. And it's getting faster. Every release is getting faster. One person had a humorous conjecture that if they keep up the current speed gains, if that trajectory is unchanged, then 3.14 will be faster than C,
来自于我们所知的工作，以及其他一些开发者，微软也为加速 Python 的发展投入了大量资金。而且它变得越来越快。每一个版本都在变得更快。曾有人作出一个幽默的推测：如果他们保持当前的速度提升，如果这种轨迹不变，那么 3.14 将比 C 语言还要快，
which of course is impossible. But I mean, that's how dramatic the shift has been so far it is huge but a lot of times people think okay well python's slow because of the gil no it has something to do with it in fact it's slower without it or they might think oh it's it's slow because it's an interpreted language i hear that a lot it's an interpreted language well interpreted language doesn't actually mean anything most of what we use is an interpreted language. Compiled just means you're moving from one code form to another, and Python's compiled too. Compiled to the bytecode. But the default Python implementation historically was slow because that bytecode had to be run by an interpreter on the end user's machine.
这当然是不可能的。但我的意思是，到目前为止的变化是多么戏剧性，它是巨大的。但很多时候人们会认为，好吧，Python 慢是因为 GIL。不，这和它有关系，事实上，没有它反而更慢。或者他们可能认为，哦，它慢是因为它是一种解释型语言，我经常听到这种说法，它是一种解释型语言。好吧，解释型语言其实没有任何意义。我们使用的大多数东西都是解释型语言。编译只是意味着你从一种代码形式转换为另一种代码形式，Python 也是经过编译的。编译成字节码。但历史上默认的 Python 实现之所以慢，是因为该字节码必须在最终用户的机器上由解释器运行。
And there's been for a long time another flavor of Python called PyPy, P-Y-P-Y. And that was a just-in-time compiler. So that actually even then had the same performance as Java because it was running in the same way that the Java JVM runs. It actually compiles two machine code at the time of execution.
并且长期以来一直有另一种风格的 Python 叫做 PyPy（P-Y-P-Y）。那是一个即时编译器。所以即使在当时，它的性能也和 Java 相同，因为它的运行方式与 Java JVM 的运行方式相同。它实际上在执行时编译成机器码。
Python was slow because Python was slow and that's improving, but there's nothing inherent about what it is or how it did things like from a design standpoint that made it slow. It's just how it was coded. And as we learn more and as we're able to examine certain parts of the code base and improve things, then we're able to examine certain parts of the code base and improve things then we're able to solve a lot of those performance issues yeah that makes sense one of the things that i first encountered when i was using python was interops you know this is something that traditionally if you want to if you want to have something in, let's say, Rust and then something in JavaScript talk to each other, well, one is running on your browser and then you're sending
Python 慢是因为 Python 本身慢，而且这种情况正在改善，但从设计角度来看，它的本质或做事方式并没有什么内在的东西使它变慢。这只是它的编码方式。随着我们了解更多，并且能够检查代码库的某些部分并改进事物，然后我们就能够检查代码库的某些部分并改进事物，然后我们就能够解决许多性能问题。是的，这说得通。我使用 Python 时最初遇到的事情之一就是互操作，你知道，这是一种传统上，如果你想让某东西用 Rust 编写，然后让某东西用 JavaScript 互相交流，好吧，一个在你的浏览器上运行，然后你发送
packets to the Rust server. And so you don't really need these languages to be built in together. But Python really introduced me to the Python C API and Boost Python and these ways to, you know, use Python and C++ together. And there's even like, you know, ways to do it in either direction where you have a C++ binary that has the Python SO and the Python VM linked into it, or, you know, Python code that has shared libraries written in c++ that it's calling into like what's your take on the overall interop kind of ecosystem and and do you tell
数据包到 Rust 服务器。所以你实际上不需要这些语言内置在一起。但 Python 确实向我介绍了 Python C API 和 Boost Python，以及这些使用 Python 和 C++ 一起工作的方法。甚至还有在任一方向上进行操作的方法，你有一个 C++ 二进制文件，其中链接了 Python SO 和 Python VM，或者你知道的，带有用 C++ 编写的共享库的 Python 代码，它正在调用这些库——你对整体互操作生态系统有什么看法，你是否告诉
people run away from that or like how do you where do you think that's going is is what's your overall take on that oh it's getting stronger if anything so there's one thing that's been holding back i think a lot of growth in this area and that is this little file as soon as i say this a bunch of python seniors out there are going to shutter spontaneously and that's python.c and that is the python the c file that provided the primary endpoints for interacting with Python from a C level. And that thing was written to work. It was not written to be pretty. It was not written to be easy to use.
人们远离它，或者你认为它将走向何方？你对此的总体看法是什么？哦，如果有的话，它变得更强大了。所以有一件事一直阻碍着我认为这一领域的很多发展，那就是这个小文件。一旦我这么说，外面的一群 Python 老兵就会不由自主地战栗，那就是 python.c。那是提供从 C 级别与 Python 交互的主要端点的 Python C 文件。那个文件编写出来是为了能工作。它不是为了好看而编写的。它不是为了易于使用而编写的。
And it certainly is usable, but it had a lot of things about it that just, it was difficult to work with. And they're in the process of deprecating that, moving away from Python C and into kind of an improved set of headers that just make working with it a lot better. Now I'm going to, full disclosure, I have never written a Python extension. I know about this from researching the book. I have not actually done it myself, but I do know I've talked to several people that have been very excited about a project called CFFI, which is this interface with Python between Python and C, and it's kind of an
它当然是可用的，但它有很多地方就是很难使用。他们正在将其弃用，从 Python C 转向一组改进的头文件，这些头文件只是让使用它变得好得多。现在我要完全坦白，我从来没有编写过 Python 扩展。我是通过研究这本书了解这一点的。我实际上自己没有做过，但我知道，我跟几个对一个名为 CFFI 的项目非常兴奋的人聊过，这是 Python 和 C 之间与 Python 的接口，它有点像是
improvement over Python.h. And this not only allows you to talk to C, but it also allows you to then make a second jump and talk to Rust or Java or what have you, whatever language happens to be out there. And so there's a lot of innovation right now in being able to make Python a part of, you know, another solution. And I've been hearing this in different capacities. There's, in general, kind of this quiet little movement happening behind the scenes with programming as a whole where some programmers are starting to move away from the walled garden model of I'm working in this ecosystem and more into this mosaic pattern where, okay, I'm writing this with a bit of Java,
对 Python.h 的改进。这不仅允许你与 C 对话，还允许你进行第二次跳转并与 Rust 或 Java 等进行对话，无论外面碰巧是哪种语言。因此，目前在使 Python 成为（你知道的）另一种解决方案的一部分方面有很多创新。我一直在不同的场合听到这一点。总的来说，编程界幕后正在发生一场安静的小运动，一些程序员开始从我在这一个生态系统中工作的有围墙的花园模式，更多地转向这种马赛克模式，即：好吧，我正在用一点 Java 编写这个，
a bit of C++, a bit of Rust, and they're pulling in pieces and they're connecting them together. And CFFI keeps coming up. And so it's interesting because I don't know which came first because I don't know enough about it, but it is kind of fun to see that. I also know there's an effort to get, not just an effort, it is working. Python is now, there's a version of Python running in WebAssembly outright. And that has enabled Python in the browser for the first time, which means that via WebAssembly in a similar way, you can bring python into uh into a project that is also using javascript because
一点 C++，一点 Rust，他们正在引入各个部分并将它们连接在一起。而 CFFI 不断被提起。所以这很有趣，因为我不知道哪个先出现，因为我对它了解不够，但看到这一点还是挺有意思的。我也知道有一项努力去实现——不仅仅是一项努力，它已经在工作了。Python 现在已经在 WebAssembly 中直接运行了一个版本。这首次使得 Python 能够在浏览器中运行，这意味着通过类似的方式经由 WebAssembly，你可以将 Python 引入到一个
python's not being turned into javascript python is python it's running in web assembly and then because javascript is also able to communicate through web assembly they're able to work together on things um so i'm seeing a lot more of this kind of mosaic pattern. And I'm excited to see what's going to come out in the next few years. Because, you know, every language has its strengths and its weaknesses and its thing. And if we can move into a space where we can pick up a language on the basis of this is good for this piece of the project because it's just easier to do this thing here. And this thing over here is easier in this language. and you don't have to decide between the two of them would be incredible that would be that would be a frankly a much saner way to move forward in some projects than having to marry one language until death do us part your your thing about
也正在使用 JavaScript 的项目中，因为 Python 没有被转换成 JavaScript，Python 就是 Python，它在 WebAssembly 中运行，然后因为 JavaScript 也能够通过 WebAssembly 进行通信，所以它们能够在一些事情上协同工作。嗯，我看到了更多这种马赛克模式。我很高兴看到未来几年会产出什么。因为，你知道，每种语言都有它的长处、短处和特性。如果我们能进入这样一个空间：我们可以基于“这对于项目的这一部分很好，因为在这里做这件事更容易”来选择一种语言，而这边的另一件事在这个语言中更容易，并且你不需要在这两者之间做出抉择，那将是不可思议的。坦率地说，对于某些项目来说，这比必须与一种语言“直到死亡将我们分离”相比，将是一种更理智的前进方式。你的
dialogue boxes comes to mind here it's like that's actually one thing that i don't know how to do in python i mean there's many things i don't have to but that's off the top of my head i wouldn't actually know it's not obvious to me how i would make a windows dialogue box pop up in python i mean i think that there's nothing and in general with with ui you know i find that the python ui story is a little strange. I mean, there's PyTK, which I've honestly never used. I don't know too much about it. PyQt seems to be pretty popular.
关于对话框的言论在这里浮现出来。这实际上是我不知道如何在 Python 中做的一件事。我的意思是，有很多事情我不知道，但脱口而出，我实际上并不知道，对我来说如何用 Python 弹出 Windows 对话框并不是显而易见的。我的意思是，我认为没有什么，总的来说，对于 UI，你知道，我发现 Python 的 UI 故事有点奇怪。我的意思是，有 PyTK，老实说我从来没有用过。我对它了解不多。PyQt 似乎相当受欢迎。
But if I want to use a web front end like Electron or one of these things, it seems to be really dominating. You know, Slack is written in Electron. Discord, the desktop client's written in Electron. It's not obvious to me how I would use Python with Electron. And so, yeah, I think the UI story in Python, what's your take on that and where's that going? I've always enjoyed UI in Python. You know, Python TK is okay for getting started,
但如果我想使用像 Electron 或类似的东西这样的网页前端，它似乎真的占了统治地位。你知道，Slack 是用 Electron 编写的。Discord，桌面客户端是用 Electron 编写的。如何将 Python 与 Electron 结合使用对我来说并不明显。所以，是的，我认为 Python 中的 UI 故事，你对此有何看法，它将走向何方？我一直很喜欢 Python 中的 UI。你知道，Python TK 对于入门来说还算可以，
but I mean, it's not beautiful by any means. Well, it can be. It depends on where you're using it. It kind of tries to mirror whatever operating system you're in to mixed effects. But like, just to create a random dialog box in a program that otherwise doesn't have a UI, that's probably the fastest
但我的意思是，它绝谈不上美观。嗯，它可以是。这取决于你在哪里使用它。它有点试图模仿你所在的操作系统，但效果参半。但是，就像在原本没有 UI 的程序中创建一个随机对话框一样，那可能是最快的
way to go about it. But I think Qt, doesn't have a ui that's probably the fastest way to go about it but um i think cute aka qt is really an interesting space because pi qt which was uh what was it river river bank i think was the company that was doing that one um that was an unofficial fork. Those are unofficial bindings. Like some other company did those bindings for Qt. So Qt, or they're officially known as Qt, wound up acquiring another project called PySide, which was just another set of Python bindings. And they made that into the official binding. So the space, the UI space in Python is, if anything, getting better because now Python is a first-class citizen in the Qt ecosystem. So they now develop officially
前进方式。但我认为 Cute——也就是 Qt，真的是一个有趣的领域。因为 PyQt，它是——是什么来着？Riverbank 似乎是做那个的公司——那是一个非官方的分支。那是官方没有直接提供的绑定。就像其他公司为 Qt 制作了这些绑定一样。所以 Qt，或者它们官方被称为 Qt，最终收购了另一个名为 PySide 的项目，这只是另一套 Python 绑定。他们将其做成了官方绑定。所以这个领域，Python 中的 UI 领域，如果说有什么变化的话，那就是在变好，因为现在 Python 是 Qt 生态系统中的一等公民。所以他们现在官方开发
in parallel the C++ and the Python bindings for Qt 5 and now Qt 6. Similarly, GTK, which is also more frequently known as GObject now, which is the whole GNOME ecosystem, that is also cross-platform. That's had bindings forever. I've done work in PyGObject before. But whether or not that works in Windows, that's GNOME's fault. It's whether or not it works in Windows, it remains to be seen. And then there's some newer libraries that are coming out.
并行为 Qt 5 以及现在的 Qt 6 提供 C++ 和 Python 绑定。同样，GTK，现在也更常被称为 GObject，也就是整个 GNOME 生态系统，它也是跨平台的。它一直都有绑定。我以前做过 PyGObject 的工作。但它是否能在 Windows 上运行，那是 GNOME 的错。它是否能在 Windows 上运行，还有待观察。然后有一些更新的库正在推出。
There's been this huge influx of Python-based UX libraries in the last few years. There's some rather interesting players in the space now. So I think that that's really starting to expand. And probably the data science and machine learning spaces are driving that because there's all these projects that are using Python for data science, using Python for AI and machine learning. And the people writing those need front ends, they need dashboards and they don't want to move out of Python. And so it was driving that need for more web-based and more native UIs.
在过去的几年里，涌现出了大量基于 Python 的 UX 库。现在该领域有一些相当有趣的参与者。所以我认为这确实开始扩展了。数据科学和机器学习领域可能正在推动这一点，因为有所有这些项目在将 Python 用于数据科学，将 Python 用于人工智能和机器学习。编写这些代码的人需要前端，他们需要仪表盘，而且他们不想离开 Python。因此，这推动了对更多基于网页和更原生 UI 的需求。
So there's a lot more options now than there were eight years ago, certainly. Patrick, you've been super quiet. I'm curious what your thoughts are, especially coming in as the guy who hated Python or maybe hates the strong word. That's a strong thing. Yeah.
所以现在的选择比八年前肯定多得多。帕特里克（Patrick），你一直非常安静。我很想知道你的想法，尤其是作为一个讨厌 Python 的人，或者说“讨厌”这个词可能有点重。那是一个很重的词。是的。
No, I mean, you guys went in a separate direction from how i would have gone but that that's good no no i think i think this has been a really interesting conversation i guess the i'll chime in on the mosaic pattern thing i think they're the oh i think cffi is c foreign function interface um just to drop it for if it wasn't obvious yeah i think clang powered a lot of that um back in interop stuff it's i think that's been sort of where the genesis has started at least that's always how i see it associated with yes the whole clang llvms i mean they they've revolutionized c
不，我的意思是，你们走的方向跟我会选择的方向截然不同，但这也挺好。不，不，我认为这真的是一次有趣的对话。我想，我会就马赛克模式的事情插话，我想那是——哦，我认为 CFFI 是 C 外部函数接口（C foreign function interface），只是为了顺便提一下，如果它还不够明显的话。是的，我认为 Clang 推动了其中很大一部分，在互操作方面。我认为这可以说是起源开始的地方，至少我总是看到它与
and c plus plus i'll make a prediction there i too am excited because i tend to do a little dabbling across languages and think that's interesting. But I think that'll go the way a bit of microservices where people will overdo it. You'll make a lot of projects that are impossible to maintain because you have that hundred lines of Haskell that like only one dude knows how to write and he's gone now. And like everyone's just like, yeah, you keep it around, hope it doesn't break kind of thing. And then you got to kind of like,
Clang、LLVM 联系在一起。我的意思是，它们彻底革新了 C 和 C++。我在这里做一个预测，我也很兴奋，因为我倾向于涉足不同的语言，并认为这很有趣。但我认为这会步微服务的后尘，人们会过度使用它。你会制作出很多无法维护的项目，因为你有那一百行只有某个家伙才知道怎么写的 Haskell 代码，而他现在已经不在了。然后大家就只是像，“是的，你留着它吧，希望它别坏”这种态度。然后你不得不像那样处理它，
it has a place in a time. I guess that's all the software engineering tropes. But I will say, I think the thing we didn't touch on that has been interesting for me is Python dependencies. So I know it got really brutal for a while going from Python 2 to Python 3
它在某个时代有其地位。我想这就是所有的软件工程老生常谈吧。但我要说，我认为我们没有触及到但对我来说很有趣的一点是 Python 的依赖项。所以我知道从 Python 2 过渡到 Python 3 的那段时间非常残酷
and whether your library would work in one or the other and just getting into the nightmare of moving from I'm writing something on my computer for me to I'm writing something as part of a team has always been a bit of a struggle for me Python as a scripting for myself great uh the pass by value versus pass by reference always stumbles stumbles for me a bit but the you know this thing of oh you had this weird version installed on your computer globally and just depended on it i need that has also gotten better with things like pi or the v and v virtual environment v e and v and i don't what's the other one that's it i don't know yeah okay so these things have made that story a lot better and most of the libraries now being python 3 compatible um has also now makes
而且你的库在其中一个版本还是两个版本中都能工作，仅仅是陷入了从“我在自己的电脑上为自己写点东西”到“我作为团队的一部分写点东西”的这种噩梦中，对我来说一直是个不小的挣扎。Python 作为我自己的脚本语言很棒，嗯，按值传递与按引用传递总是让我有点绊脚石似的一知半解，但你知道，这种“哦，你的电脑全局安装了这个奇怪的版本并且完全依赖它，我需要那个”的情况，随着像 pip 或者是 venv（虚拟环境）等工具的出现也有所改善，而且——等等，另一个是什么来着？就是那个，我不知道，好吧。所以这些事情让这个故事好多了，现在大多数库都兼容 Python 3，嗯，这也使得
python 3 actually usable after what a decade or something ridiculous uh so i feel that there's been a lot of growth there um and i'm curious to to know i guess like what your thought is you sort of sounds like lean in on the right Python is Python. Don't worry so much about the typing. You can get all these things. There's been a lot of movement. I see again, not being part of this space, but people talking about adding type hints to their Python programs as a way
Python 3 在经历了十年还是什么荒谬的时间后真正变得可用了；所以我感觉那里的成长很多，而且我很好奇想知道，我猜你的想法是什么，你听起来有点倾向于，正确的看法是：Python 就是 Python。别太担心类型。你可以获得所有这些东西。有很多动向。我再次看到，虽然我不是这个领域的一部分，但人们在谈论为他们的 Python 程序添加类型提示（type hints），作为一种
to support those. What do they call them? The Illities maintainability, scalability across teams reproduced with testability. I mean, that was a lot rambling, sorry, but I am all stored up.ability. I mean, that was a lot. Rambly. Sorry. But I'm
支持这些特性的方法。他们管这叫什么来着？“可维护性”、“跨团队的可扩展性”、“可重现性”以及“可测试性”。我是说，刚才那话有点语无伦次，抱歉，但我积压了太多想法。可测试性。我是说，那真的是一大堆。语无伦次。抱歉。但我
all stored up. I don't know. Feel free to respond or comment on any of those. Yeah. Well, I can respond to both of those. So one of the topics I've been passionate about is this issue of Python packaging. And I gave a talk a couple of times called
已经积压太多了。我不知道。随时可以对其中任何一点做出回应或评论。是的。好吧，这两点我都可以回应。所以，我一直热衷的主题之一就是 Python 打包这个问题。我曾多次做过一个演讲，叫做
Escaping the Cargo Cult. So Python has been haunted by this phenomenon called cargo cult programming is specifically in the space of packaging and this is what led to a lot of the nightmares like virtual environments aren't new pip being able to install packages not new the main problem in that space has been that people don't understand how python packaging works and so they kept they kept inventing it again. And they weren't inventing it because they were trying to understand it. They were inventing it because they thought there was nothing there. And so they would just try to figure it out. And then when they would
《逃离货货崇拜》（Escaping the Cargo Cult）。所以 Python 一直被一种叫做“货轮崇拜编程”（cargo cult programming）的现象所困扰，特别是在打包领域，而这正是导致许多噩梦的原因——比如虚拟环境并不新鲜，pip 能够安装包也不新鲜。该领域的主要问题一直是人们不理解 Python 打包是如何工作的，所以他们不断地重新发明它。他们重新发明它不是因为他们试图去理解它，而是因为他们以为那里什么都没有。所以他们只是试图去弄清楚它。然后当他们
half figure something out, then they'd say, hey, I figured it out. Here's a template. And then they start passing that around. And someone else would copy that template and modify it and understand none of it. And so you have this compounding problem of just all of these projects with these setup.py files that were just not reasonable, rational or reusable. And all these assumptions that were leaking, you know, because every time you copy and paste code, you were copying and pasting the assumptions in the headspace of the programmer who wrote it. And most of those assumptions are not going to apply to your project. So you're going to have to then go back and understand what it is you just copy pasted and vet whether or not those assumptions even make sense. That's assuming you can find them all. This is why I'm a huge advocate for if you find something on Stack Overflow, take 10 minutes and literally retype the whole thing.
半懂不懂地弄清楚了一点之后，就会说：“嘿，我搞懂了。这是一个模板。”然后他们开始到处散播这个模板。另一个人就会复制那个模板，修改它，却完全不理解其中的原理。于是你就有了一个复合型的问题：所有这些项目都带着那些既不合理、不理性也不可重用的 setup.py 文件。而且所有这些假设都在泄露，你知道的，因为每次你复制代码和粘贴时，你都在复制和粘贴编写它的程序员的思维方式中的假设。而大多数这些假设并不适用于你的项目。所以你不得不回过头去理解你刚刚复制粘贴的东西，并审查这些假设是否甚至有意义。这还是假设你能把它们全都找出来。这就是为什么我强烈主张：如果你在 Stack Overflow 上找到了什么东西，花 10 分钟，字面意义上重新把整段代码敲一遍。
Just retype it. Just that mere action of retyping it is going to force you to interact with it at such a granular level that you're going to stop and go, why am I doing this? And it's going to lead you to vet those assumptions. So the Python packaging space has improved a lot. Part of it was the creation of the unofficial official body called the Python Packaging Authority. And they don't really have any official, they're like the advisory board. They're the people that build the packaging tools and they help steer Python in terms of packaging, but they don't really have any sort of, you know, you know, hammer to hit anyone over the head with, although the name deliberately
就重新敲一遍。仅仅是重新敲代码这个动作，就会迫使你在如此精细的层面上与它交互，以至于你会停下来想：“我为什么要这样做？”这会引导你去审查那些假设。因此，Python 打包领域已经有了很大的改善。部分原因是一个名为 Python 打包权威机构（Python Packaging Authority）的非官方官方机构的建立。他们实际上没有任何官方权力，他们就像是顾问委员会。他们是构建打包工具的人，他们帮助引导 Python 在打包方面的发展，但他们其实没有任何那种……你知道的……可以用来敲击任何人的锤子，尽管这个名字故意
makes it sound like they do. And they've helped bring a lot of clarity to this space, moving away from the setup.py files, which were, it just tempted people to write too much convoluted logic to try and package. And they moved more towards the setup.cfg and pyprojectoml files, which are declarative. They say, you're describing your project in a fairly standard fashion, and then you can pick a backend. Do you want to use setup tools? Do you want to use poetry? Do you want to use flit? And so that's reduced a lot of that insanity. And it's also standardized things like stating what your dependencies are and pinning versions for those dependencies. And so that has really driven a lot of the improvement in this space.
让人觉得他们有。他们帮助为这个领域带来了很多清晰度，摆脱了 setup.py 文件——这种文件只会诱使人们为了打包而编写过多错综复杂的逻辑。他们更多地转向了 setup.cfg 和 pyproject.toml 文件，它们是声明式的。它们的意思是：你以一种相当标准的方式描述你的项目，然后你可以选择一个后端。你想用 setup.tools 吗？你想用 poetry 吗？你想用 flit 吗？因此，这减少了许多那种疯狂状态。它还标准化了一些事情，比如声明你的依赖项是什么，以及为这些依赖项锁定版本。所以这确实推动了这个领域的很多改进。
If anyone is listening and thinking, you know, I'm struggling with this too, the two things I would do is, number one, figure out your packaging early, as early in the project as possible. I one time built a game. It took me a month to build the game. It took me two years to package it. I am not kidding. Thank you, Kivy, for literally declaring that shipping to the end user is an edge case. I wish I was kidding that I'm quoting the maintainer. So figure out your packaging early. Figure it out at first, if at all possible. Second is do out-of-place testing. Write your tests in a separate folder from your source. So you have your source folder, SRC, put your Python packages under that. Have as many packages as you want,
如果有人在听，并且心想：“你知道的，我也在为这个苦恼”，我会做的两件事是：第一，尽早弄清楚你的打包，在项目尽可能早的阶段。我曾经做过一个游戏。我花了一个月的时间做这个游戏。我花了两两年时间来打包它。我没有开玩笑。谢谢 Kivy，它实际上宣布将软件交付给最终用户是一个“边缘情况”。我希望我不是在开玩笑，我是在引用维护者的话。所以，尽早弄清楚你的打包。如果可能的话，一开始就把它搞定。第二是进行“域外测试”（out-of-place testing）。把你的测试写在一个与源码分开的文件夹里。所以你有你的源码文件夹，SRC，把你的 Python 包放在那下面。想放多少包就放多少包，
but put all your packages under that. Put your packaging files external to that, so in the root of your repository, and then adjacent to, not inside of, adjacent to your source folder, put your tests folder. Write your tests there. What this is going to do is it's going to force you to only be able to run those tests in a virtual environment that has installed your package, which means that all the assumptions you've been making about your current working directory and about it works on my machine are going to break. And you hit those problems early on and you hit them often. Every time you make one of those faulty assumptions, your tests are going to break. And so you can solve it while it's still solvable. Great tip. You also touched on annotations, but I can come back around to
但把所有的包都放在那下面。把你的打包文件放在外部，也就是放在仓库的根目录下，然后紧挨着——不是在内部，是紧挨着——你的源码文件夹，放一个你的 tests（测试）文件夹。把你的测试写在那里。这样做会产生什么效果呢？它会迫使你只能在一个已经安装了你的包的虚拟环境中运行这些测试，这意味着你一直以来关于当前工作目录以及“它在我的机器上能运行”的所有假设都会被打破。你会在早期就遇到这些问题，并且会经常遇到。每当你做出其中一个错误的假设时，你的测试就会崩溃。所以你可以在问题还能解决的时候解决它。好建议。你还提到了注解，但我可以回过头来谈谈
that if you have any follow-up thoughts on packaging. No, I think that was great. I mean, like I said, I feel there's been, this is probably wrong, but I feel there's been a sophistication growth in this sort of like, for people like me who, I won't say expert, that's maybe a bridge too too far but do a lot of programming in other languages to interact with python and be productive by finding resources on stuff like how to get set up with a proper environment how to make sure to get your dependencies bring across is a huge thing and to be clear do most of my programming in c++ dependent story dependency story is easier because it's non-existent yeah several people attempting
如果你对打包还有任何后续想法的话。不，我觉得那很棒。我是说，就像我说的，我感觉有，这可能不对，但我感觉在某种程度上有一种复杂性的增长——对于像我这样的人来说，我不会说自己是专家，那可能有点言过其实了，但在其他语言中做大量编程来与 Python 交互，并通过寻找关于如何设置正确的环境、如何确保引入依赖项等资源的资料来提高生产力，这是一件大事——而且要明确的是，我大部分的编程都是在 C++ 中完成的，依赖项的故事更容易，因为压根儿就不存在。是的，有几个人试图
to do it but you just basically know as far as i know a significant fraction of people just use no dependency management and so i i shouldn't throw stones but i just say that you know there's that assumption in python you're going to sit down you're going to bring all these batteries included batteries not you know you bring them all in and then you just go and when it works amazing and you know i think that yeah we were talking about annotations for types and i think that was the other uh thing for me is how do i go from writing a script for myself and make sure that when i put that up on on you know the team's github and they go pull it down that not only it runs dependencies but also that they when they're looking at one function
去这样做，但你基本上知道，据我所知，相当一部分人根本不使用任何依赖项管理。所以我不应该扔石头砸人，但我只是想说，你知道，Python 中有这样一种假设：你坐下来，你会把所有这些“内置电池”（batteries included）——电池不在……你知道的，你把它们全带上，然后你就可以出发了，当它奏效时，那真是太棒了。并且，你知道，我认为是的，我们之前在谈论用于类型的注解，我想对我来说另一件……的事情是：我如何从为自己写一个脚本，转变为确保当我把它放到团队的 GitHub 上、他们去把它拉下来时，不仅它能运行依赖项，而且当他们在查看某个函数时，
how are they understanding what's expected to be coming in what's getting returned that was always something that uh was a bit foreign yeah and and i was one other note i'll mention on the packaging front you said it seems like a sophistication i would actually say it's a desophistication they were they were sophisticating themselves right into obscurity is what they were doing and like everybody was being super sophisticated about their packaging at, to the point of being esoteric. And so it was, it was, that was part of the problem. I think, you know, C++ never had the opportunity to be sophisticated, like to your point that you just, you, you download and you compile the thing. Or you bring in a DLL or some such nonsense.
他们如何理解期望传入什么、返回什么？这对我来说一直是一个有点陌生的东西。是的，顺便提一下我在打包方面的一点看法，你刚才说这似乎是一种“复杂化”（sophistication），我实际上会说这是一种“去复杂化”（desophistication）。他们过去是在把事情搞得越来越复杂，直到走向默默无闻，这就是他们当时在做的事。就像每个人都在他们的打包上表现得超级复杂，达到了晦涩难懂的地步。所以这……这正是问题的一部分。我认为，你知道，C++ 从来没有机会变得复杂，就像你说的，你下载并编译那个东西。或者你引入一个 DLL 或一些诸如此类的无稽之谈。
And there's almost an assumption that this is going to hurt. So, you know, that's just an assumption right off the bat. Whereas because people were trying to make it as easy to package in Python as it was to write in Python, but they didn't understand the space,
并且几乎有一种假设，认为这会很痛苦。所以，你知道，这从一开始就是一个假设。然而，由于人们试图让 Python 中的打包像用 Python 编写一样简单，但他们并不理解这个领域，
they were creating these really sophisticated solutions that weren't actually sophisticated at all. They were just cerebral. And because you take two cerebral things and slam them together, they're not going to work because they're two completely different thought spaces. So de-sophisticating it, making it more obvious, more like you don't have as much say now as you used to.
他们创造了这些非常复杂的解决方案，而这些方案实际上一点也不复杂。它们只是纯粹的烧脑。因为你把两个烧脑的东西猛烈撞击在一起，它们是不会起作用的，因为它们是两个完全不同的思维空间。所以，将其去复杂化，让它更直观，更像是……你现在不像过去那样拥有那么大的发言权了。
And that's really a good thing because you shouldn't be reinventing packaging more than likely. To the type annotation thing, I think the thing that I understand about type annotations is Python is not JavaScript. And that was, I think, one of the driving factors that led to it being put in there. As I mentioned earlier, a value is still strictly typed but you're strictly typing it on the basis of what it can do or you're interacting with those types on the basis of what they can do and so pythons always had this saying explicit is better than implicit it's part of the this poem called the zenith python that is kind of the tongue-in-cheek driver
这其实是一件好事，因为你多半不应该去重新发明打包。对于类型注解这件事，我认为我所理解的关于类型注解的是：Python 不是 JavaScript。我认为这是导致它被引入其中的驱动因素之一。正如我前面提到的，一个值仍然是严格类型的，但你是在它能做什么的基础上对它进行严格类型的，或者你是在它们能做什么的基础上与这些类型进行交互的。所以 Python 一直有这样一句名言：“显式优于隐式”（explicit is better than implicit）。它是这首名为《Python 之禅》（The Zen of Python）的诗的一部分，这首诗可以说是该语言中
of decision-making in the language. Like, this is the best way to describe what our priorities are as a language. It was written in jest, but as you'll notice very quickly with Python programmers, the line between kidding and serious is spider silk thin. So it's usually when we're making a joke, we're also being dead serious about it at the same time.
决策的半开玩笑式的驱动力。就像，这是描述我们作为一门语言的优先级最好的方式。它是开玩笑写的，但正如你很快会从 Python 程序员身上注意到的那样，开玩笑和认真的界限比蛛丝还要薄。所以通常当我们在开玩笑时，我们在同一时间也是极其认真的。
Amazingly passive-aggressive bunch. I love them, though. So type annotations became a way of explicitly defining the assumptions that you're making about what you can do with the value. You don't, in most cases, actually... Python does not actually use those type annotations itself. That's, the term annotation is deliberate. It's like a comment. It's a special type of comment that is just a reference for the software developer slash the static analysis tool like
真是一群被动攻击性极强的人。不过我还是很喜欢他们。所以，类型注解成为了一种显式定义你对“你可以用这个值做什么”的假设的方法。在大多数情况下，你实际上……Python 自身其实并不会使用这些类型注解。对，annotation（注解）这个词是刻意选用的。它就像一个注释。它是一种特殊类型的注释，仅仅是供软件开发人员或静态分析工具（例如
MyPy to be able to look at it and go, you're breaking this assumption. And that's helpful because not everything fits neatly into this little bucket of type annotations. There's some times where you just finally, you're tearing your hair out, you just shut it off because there's just no way to do it. But most of the time, it's pretty reasonable to be able to say, this is, here's the assumptions I'm making. This thing you're passing in should be iterable because I'm going to be using it in a loop.
MyPy）参考用的，以便它们能够查看它并说：“你正在打破这个假设。”这很有帮助，因为并不是所有东西都能整齐地塞进类型注解这个小桶里。有时你简直急得抓耳挠腮，最后只好把它关掉，因为根本没有办法做到。但大多数时候，能够说“这就是我所做的假设，你传入的这个东西应该是可迭代的（iterable），因为我将把它用在循环中”，这是相当合理的。
So this should be an iterable. And this should be integer because I'm going to assume it's a numeric value without a decimal point, and so on and so forth. So you're really describing the sort of data that you're expecting to be fit into those spaces. Now, I say it's rarely used by Python itself. There is one exception, and that is those single dispatch methods I mentioned earlier. It will actually look at the type annotation in that case, and the code itself will use that to determine which of the single dispatch functions to call based on the type of data that was passed in
“所以这应该是一个可迭代对象。而这应该是一个整数（integer），因为我假设它是一个没有小数点的数值，诸如此类。”因此，你实际上是在描述你期望填入这些空间的的数据类型。现在，我说它很少被 Python 本身使用，但有一个例外，那就是我前面提到的那些单分派（single dispatch）方法。在这种情况下，它实际上会查看类型注解，并且代码本身会根据传递给函数第一个参数的数据类型，
to the first argument of the function. And so it can switch. I think match statements also can work with type two, actually. The new match statements. Yeah, that makes sense. So I wanted to give a bit of time here to talk about Dead Simple Python. So this is a book that you wrote. It took an extraordinary amount of time and effort.
来决定调用哪个单分派函数。所以它可以切换。我想 match 语句其实也可以和类型一起工作，实际上。新的 match 语句。是的，这说得通。所以我在这里想留出一点时间来谈谈《极简 Python》（Dead Simple Python）。所以这是你写的一本书。它花了极其大量的精力和时间。
You had to read through the guts of Python many times, talk to the core developers. A lot of them are editors on the book. And kind of talk us a little bit through, you know, who is the target audience for this book? And how do you expect that audience to use the book? Is it something where you expect people to read it cover to cover? Is it a encyclopedia or people are going to go to a specific chapter when they need to? You know, what's the audience and how are they going to use it? Sure. And I do have to, in full disclosure, clarify something.
你不得不很多次通读 Python 的底层内部机制，与核心开发者交流。他们中有很多人是这本书的编辑。能不能跟我们稍微讲讲，这本书的目标受众是谁？你希望受众如何使用这本书？这是一本你期望人们从头到尾阅读的书吗？它是一本百科全书，还是人们在需要时会去查阅特定的章节？你知道的，受众是谁，他们会怎么使用它？当然。不过我必须在完全坦白的前提下澄清一件事。
None of the core developers I spoke to were editors on the book. Python experts certainly are the editors, but none of them are. A core developer is someone who actually develops the Python language, and none of the guys who edited the book are officially mandated core developers. But I did talk to a couple of core developers in writing it. There are a couple of thank yous in there from some. In particular, the guy responsible for writing the Asynchrony Library
我交谈过的核心开发者中，没有一个人是这本书的编辑。Python 专家当然是编辑，但他们都不是。核心开发者是指真正开发 Python 语言的人，而编辑这本书的这些人中，没有一个是被官方授权的核心开发者。但我写书的时候确实跟几个核心开发者聊过。里面有对其中一些人的致谢。特别是负责编写异步库的那个人
actually took a look at that chapter and helped me future-proof it. There's a couple others, which I appreciate. Anyway, but Dead Simple Python was written for people who know another programming language. And they want to understand Python deeply. Or maybe they even know a bit of Python. Maybe they've worked in Python before. But they continually find themselves baffled by the obvious solution so there's another saying on python is there should be uh one obvious way
实际上看了一下那一章，并帮我使其具备了面向未来的兼容性。还有其他几个人，对此我很感激。无论如何，《极简 Python》是为那些懂另一种编程语言的人写的。他们想要深入理解 Python。或者也许他们甚至懂一点 Python。也许他们以前在 Python 中工作过。但他们不断发现自己被显而易见的解决方案所困惑——所以 Python 中还有另一句名言是：应该有……嗯……一种显而易见的方法
to do things and that seems very glib until you read the next line of the zen of python which says that way may not be obvious unless you're Dutch, which is a reference to Guido. And basically the term simple in terms of this book and the term obvious in Python mean the same thing. It's not obvious or simple looking forward. You're looking at the problem. You're going, how in God's green earth am I supposed to do this? I can think of 50 different ways, which way is right. It's only obvious or simple retrospectively.
去做事情，这听起来像是空洞的陈述，直到你读到《Python之禅》的下一行，上面说这种方式可能并不显眼，除非你是荷兰人，这是在指代Guido。基本上，这本书里的“简单”一词和Python里的“显眼”一词意思是一样的。向前看时，它并不显眼或简单。你看着这个问题，心里想，天哪，我到底该怎么做？我能想出50种不同的方法，到底哪一种才是对的。它只有在事后回顾时才是显眼或简单的。
Once you've actually found the best way to do it, then you look back and you go, of course, nothing else would have made sense. It clicks. It's got that sort of psychological snap to it that you just like, this makes more sense than anything else I could have thought of. But only once you know it. And so the whole goal of the book is to help people develop that sort of ability to see things, to see the one obvious way, in figure quotes, forward instead of just backwards. And I do that by explaining, well, first of all, I skip all of the sort of boring, you know, this is what a loop
一旦你真正找到了最好的方法，然后回过头来看，你会觉得，理所当然，其他任何方式都说不通。它一下子就对上了。它有一种心理上的契合感，让你觉得，这比我想象的任何其他东西都更有意义。但前提是你要知道答案。所以这本书的全部目的，就是帮助人们培养那种看待事物、看到那条用引号括起来的“显眼之路”的能力，而不是只停留在事后诸葛亮。我是通过以下方式做到的：首先，我跳过了所有那些无聊的内容，你知道的，什么是循环
is, this is what a variable is. This is what a variable is. This is what a function is. You know this stuff. You don't need a refresher. But what matters to someone picking up the Python language is what is a loop in Python? What's special about a loop in Python? What's special about a variable or a function in Python? So understanding what makes it unique in this language.
是什么，什么是变量是什么。什么是变量是什么。什么是函数是什么。这些东西你都知道。你不需要温习。但对于一个刚接触Python语言的人来说，重要的是：Python中的循环是什么？Python中的循环有什么特别之处？Python中的变量或函数有什么特别之处？因此，要理解是什么让它在这门语言中独一无二。
So the approach I take throughout the book is I will start from what I call the most sugar-free version. Like I will, it'll be Python code, but it won't have any of the, any of the fancy specials of I'm literally doing it the most manual way possible. And then I add layer upon layer of abstraction. So by the time you actually get to that for loop or that assignment statement or whatever, you're going, oh, so what's actually under the hood is this. And because you understand what's under the hood, then it becomes sort of a pattern substitution.
所以在整本书中我采取的方法是，我从我称之为“无糖”的版本开始。就像我会写，它是Python代码，但它不会有任何花哨的特殊功能，我完全是用最手动的方式来做。然后我一层又一层地添加抽象。所以当你真正接触到那个for循环、赋值语句或诸如此类的东西时，你会恍然大悟：哦，原来底层实际上是这样的。正因为你理解了底层原理，它就变成了一种模式替换。
And you understand why you're using a for loop. It's because, okay, this is, I'm iterating and I'm iterating in this way. And so it really enables you to understand the whys and the wherefores of Pythonic patterns in a way that you can then apply it to your own code. The other thing I did with this book is I didn't give a project. There's tons of examples that you type through with me and they're snarly in all the right places. Like I don't make any of them behave nicely. I took a lot of time to make these like really examples that really had a lot of hidden surprises where it would break in unexpected places. And you'd have to understand why is it breaking here
而且你也会明白为什么要使用for循环。原因很简单，我在进行迭代，而且是以这种方式迭代。因此，它确实能让你理解Python式模式的所以然，从而将其应用到你自己的代码中。关于这本书，我做的另一件事是没有提供单一的项目。这里有大量的示例，你需要和我一起输入代码，而且它们在各个正确的地方都非常棘手。我没有让其中任何一个表现得温顺。我花了很多时间来制作这些包含大量隐藏惊喜的示例，它们会在意想不到的地方报错。你必须理解它为什么会报错
and how do we fix that? But I didn't give any project because the assumption was you're probably writing some code. You probably already have a goal in mind. You don't need me to hand you something to do. You're already doing something. What you need is the tools necessary to be able to solve that problem. So you could work through it cover to cover, but it is also written on the basis that you can just drop right to the chapter on the thing you're working with like okay I'm how does asynchrony work in Python you can drop right into that and the only assumption it's gonna make is that
以及我们如何修复它。但我没有给出任何项目，因为假设你可能正在写一些代码。你心里可能已经有了目标。你不需要我塞给你一些事情做。你已经在做了。你需要的是能够解决该问题的必要工具。所以你可以从头到尾读完它，但它也是基于这样一种前提编写的：你可以直接跳到你正在使用的那一章，比如：好吧，Python中的异步是如何工作的？你可以直接跳转到那一章，它唯一的假设是
anything that's been defined in a previous chapter I don't need to go through again if you do need it there's an index as a glossary you can turn back if you need to but it focuses on each piece at a time, layer after layer. So by the time you get through the whole book, you've covered the entire core language. Front to back. And even touched on a few of the libraries in the process. That was the approach I took with the book. That's awesome.
在前面章节中定义过的任何内容，我都不需要再次复习。如果你确实需要，后面有索引和词汇表，需要时可以翻看。但它一次只专注于一个部分，层层递进。所以当你读完整本书时，你就已经涵盖了整个核心语言。从头到尾。在这个过程中甚至还触及了一些库。这就是我写这本书时采用的方法。太棒了。
Yeah, I mean, I think you mentioned a couple of decisions on how to communicate the book and like what to write. And I always appreciate that that's one of the things with programming books in particular. You said best practices before. I'll say sometimes people give this is the best book. You want to learn. So like this is the best book. And I always find it's like, really? Like the tone of the book, the style, like learn such and such in four hours. Always the wrong answer.
是的，我的意思是，我认为你提到了关于如何传达这本书以及写什么的一些决定。我一直很欣赏这一点，特别是对于编程书来说。你之前提到了最佳实践。我会说有时候人们会给出“这是最好的书”这种评价。你想学编程，所以“这是最好的书”。我总觉得，真的吗？比如这本书的语气、风格，像“四小时学会某某语言”。这总是错误的答案。
You can never learn it in that many hours. It's always a lot. But other than that, you know, I think like it's sometimes you just need a certain kind of communication style. Maybe it's watching a YouTube video. Maybe it's, you know, reading a book. I think that I just love the fact that I feel for our field that we just have so much diversity in how to express the concepts. And somebody does need to learn how to write a for loop, but you don't have to write a book for them. You can write a book for the person who says, yeah, I know what it is. Cut to the good part, right?
你绝对无法在那么多小时内学会。它总是需要很多时间。但除此之外，你知道，有时候你只是需要某种特定的沟通方式。也许是看YouTube视频，也许是读一本书。我非常喜欢我们这个领域在表达概念方面有多样性。确实有人需要学习如何编写for循环，但你不必为他们写书。你可以为这样的人写书：是的，我知道那是什么。直接切入正题，对吧？
The part where like, what makes it special? Exactly. I mean, there are, and this is one of the reasons why I signed up for this book because there are a thousand books for here's how to code for the first time in Python. There's some great ones, you know,
那种探讨“是什么让它变得特别”的部分？没错。我的意思是，有，这也是我签下这本书的原因之一，因为市面上有一千本关于“如何在Python中进行第一次编程”的书。有一些非常棒的书，你知道的，
Python crash course, the automate the boring stuff with python uh anything about swagger it's awesome you know there's the there's many others besides that that i could point to it's a lot of great books for learning python for beginners but i noticed that with python in particular that there were exactly two types of books on the market there was the python for beginners and then there was, here's how to train a neural network to recognize pictures of cats versus pictures of squashes running on a Raspberry Pi that is running on a potato battery in your grandmother's basement. Those are the only two types of books there are for Python. And there's this crater in the middle
《Python编程从入门到实践》、《Python自动化办公》……任何关于Swagger的书都很棒，你知道的，除了这些还有很多其他的好书可以推荐。对于初学者来说，有很多学习Python的好书，但我注意到，尤其是对于Python，市场上基本上只有两类书。一类是Python初学者指南，另一类是：如何训练神经网络来识别猫的照片与南瓜的照片，这些照片运行在树莓派上，而树莓派则靠你奶奶地下室里的马铃薯电池供电。Python的书只有这两种。而在中间却有一个巨大的空白
for all the people who are like, I'm not doing data science, machine learning, or this random Django thing over here. I just need to know how to write a list comprehension that makes sense. And that lack of those sorts of things in book form really drove this. So I hope there will be more people inspired by this to write similar books. I would love for there to be competition. Oh, that's great. But yeah, I think there was one book that was that was pretty close and i would i won't i won't name it because i don't want to i don't want to poke fun at a fellow author but
留给那些并非在做数据科学、机器学习或某个随机的Django项目的人。我只是需要知道如何编写一个通顺的列表推导式。图书市场上缺乏这类内容，真正促成了这本书的诞生。所以我希望有更多人能受到启发来写类似的书。我很乐意看到竞争。哦，那太棒了。不过，是的，我想曾经有一本书非常接近这个方向，我不会说出它的名字，因为我不想开玩笑戏弄同行作者，但是
i was asked like okay well is this similar and i'm like no it's not because i can look just like it lists comprehension it's like this is just a simple four and in range of you know one to eight it's like what about conditionals what about accessing sub keys on it what about unpacking a tuple in the middle of it like none of this is half of it's not even documented and that's kind of the funny thing is like i had to really dig into how does this work at all because no one wrote it down so that was fun well jason this has been great uh we have you know just a couple minutes and we gotta head out but what if people want to catch up with you follow so obviously the book anything else like people to keep up with you or check out yeah um you know in general links to every, I am ubiquitously found online as code mouse nine,
有人问我：好吧，这和那本类似吗？我说：不，它不一样。因为我看到它讲列表推导式时，就只是一个简单的`for i in range(1 to 8)`。那条件判断呢？如何访问其中的子键？如何在中间解包一个元组？这些内容全都没有，甚至有一半连文档里都没有。这其实挺有趣的，我不得不深入研究这到底是怎么运作的，因为根本没人写下来。所以这很有趣。好了，杰森，这次访谈太棒了，我们还有几分钟就要结束了，但如果人们想联系你、关注你，除了书之外，还有什么地方可以让大家关注你或了解你呢？好的，总的来说，我在网上的各个地方都有链接，我的全网用户名都是codemouse9,
two. So anywhere that I am, that's my screen name. I am. I just left the big bird blue site, the big blue bird site. Excuse me. I got that backwards.
二。所以无论我在哪里，那都是我的网名。我。我刚刚离开了那只大鸟蓝色的网站，那个大蓝色鸟的网站。对不起。我把顺序弄倒了。
It was getting a bit musky in there. So I am now on. If anyone's buying me code mouse nine, do it. Mastodon dot online. I have a terrible pun every monday too so be forewarned if you follow me prepare to groan and i can be found on irc pretty frequently as well i don't know i've been unplugging a lot more from social media linkedin's
那里面开始变得有点像马斯克味了。所以我现在在。如果有人在找我，codemouse9，来mastodon.net在线找我吧。我每周一也会有一个糟糕的双关语，所以如果关注我，请做好心理准备，准备发出呻吟吧。我也经常在IRC上出没。我不知道，我最近减少了很多社交媒体的使用，领英（LinkedIn）
pretty good too um but whenever i write new articles or whatever they're probably going to be on dev.to that's a neat community to check out. And then there's also my podcast, Bug Hunters Cafe. So I talk about debugging on there, so that can be fun too. Well, awesome. Thanks. I thought that was an awesome, I mean, covered a whirlwind of topics like basic,
也挺不错的，不过每当我写新文章的时候，它们大概都会发布在dev.to上，那是一个很棒的社区，值得去看看。然后还有我的播客，Bug Hunters Cafe。我在那里讨论调试，所以那也会很有趣。太棒了。谢谢。我认为这是一次非常棒的经历，涵盖了从基础到
sophisticated, we're all over the map. That was amazing. Definitely plenty of brain food here to kind of think about and ponder. But thanks for being on the show. It's been a great time. And thanks to all of our listeners again for hanging with us another episode. And we'll see you all next time. See you later.
高深的话题，我们无所不包。这太神奇了。这里绝对有大量的精神食粮可供思考和琢磨。非常感谢你来到节目。这是一段美好的时光。也要再次感谢所有陪伴我们又度过一期节目的听众朋友们。我们下期再见。再见。
See ya. music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I, and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。音乐由Eric Barn Dollar提供。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及进行混音和改编，但您必须署名Patrick和我，并采用相同的许可方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。